OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT WILL COME TO ORDER A
GOOD ATERNOON EVERYONE
RESPONSIBLE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES HE COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TWO OF THE
PUBLIC. WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS. IT
WILL. WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE AN ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX FIVE FOUR TWO
EIGHT NINE SEVEN. AGAIN THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER.
844-291-6364 ACCESS CODE IS SIX
FIVE FOUR EIGHT NINE SEVEN FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS. PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
THIS IS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER HE
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED. INTERNAL READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEES PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY IN TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. THIS IS
IMPORTANT YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
EVERY EFFORT BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINING PROCESS AND
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL PATIENT SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES. CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE SIX BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA A SCHOOL NOW
BEGIN TO BILL HEARING- LET ME
FIRST ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
BEFORE WE CALL ON. OF THE FIRST
BILL. THE CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WITH FEDER
CORTESE- CORTEZ HERE SENATOR
CHAU BOOK. CENTER OF BOKE HERE
CENTERED AROUND. YEAH CENTERED
AROUND HERE SO LAYERED HERE.
SKINNER LAYERED HERE CENTER
NEWMAN HERE CENTER NEWMAN HERE.
ALL RIGHT TO THE CONSOLE NOTES
CORPSMAN BEEN A STEP. THE NEXT
TO COME IS NEEDS TO OR
COMMITTEE UNLESS THERE'S AN
OBJECT WE WILL WITH A THE RULES
YOU KNOW CONSENT. BUT HEARING
NO OBJECTION THE ROOM ARE DAHLE
BY CONSENT. BUT NOW. WE'LL HEAR
FROM FIRST ALL. WELCOME SENATOR
WILL. FIMI PRESENTER ON YOUR
BILL SB FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER SB
FIFTY WHICH ENJOY AUTHORED WITH
CENTER FOR TWO. WITH PROHIBIT
ET FROM A END OF SOCIAL
SECURITY NO IN ITS TOP MOST
CALMLY MAIL DOCUMENTS LIST THE
NUMBER IS REPLACE WITH A
MODIFIED UNIQUE IDENTIFIER. IN
THIS DAY AND AGE IT IS
INCONCEIVABLE THAT ANY STATE
AGENCY WOULD INCLUDE
INDIVIDUALS MOST IMPORTANT
PERSONAL INFORMATION. ON
UNSECURED CORRESPONDENCE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE'VE LEARNED
THIS PAST YEAR LITTLE ABOUT THE
EDT IS MODERN OR FUNCTIONAL.
THE STATE AUDITOR REDNECK
RECOMMENDED THIS PRACTICE BE
DONE AWAY WITH BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN. YET IT
REPORTED NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR
THAT EDT HAS CONTINUE TO PLACE
CALIFORNIANS AT RISK OF
IDENTITY THEFT BY NOT COMPLYING
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION- THIS
IS MORE CONCERNING NOW SLASH
YOUR SURGEON PANDEMIC RELATED
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CLAIMS
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED
CORRESPONDENCE. WE ARE ALL
AWARE THAT UNEMPLOYMENT FRAUD
IS RAMPANT DURING THIS PANDEMIC
WITH OVER TEN POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS TO POTENTIALLY
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS BEING PAID
OUT BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY.
BUREAUCRATIC MALAISE IS NO
EXCUSE FOR PUTTING CALIFORNIA'S
IDENTITIES AT RISK AND ALTHOUGH
THERE IS NO DIRECTLY. THERE
EXIST A STRONG POSSIBILITY THAT
THIS CONTINUE PRACTICE PLACE
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS IDENTITIES
AT RISK FOR THE FRAUD THAT
EVENTUALLY OCCURRED. MEMBERS I
HAVE SHARED WITH THE COMMITTEE
MY INTENTION TO AMEND THE BILL
IN JUDICIARY COMMITTEE FOR THIS
REQUIREMENT TO APPLY ALL
CORRESPONDENCE REGARDLESS. OF
WHAT'S REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW
IRWIN RETURNING AN INDIVIDUAL'S
PERSONAL DOCUMENTS THE
AMENDMENTS WOULD ALSO SET THE
DATE AS OCTOBER FIRST IS THAT
DATE. FOR COMPLIANCE OF THE
BILL WELL CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
STATE AGENCIES TO TRUNCATE AN
INDIVIDUAL SO SECURITY NUMBER
ON ANY OUTGOING. CORRESPONDENCE
BY JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE IT IS EVIDENT THAT WE
CANNOT WAIT FOR E. D. TO COMPLY
UNTIL THEN. THESE MEMBERS WILL
GREATLY IMPROVE THE BILL AND I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE SO THIS BILL
TO MOVE FORWARD. BUT WITH ME
TODAY I HOPE HOPE IS ONLINE-
BECAUSE HE'S NOT HE- TO PROVIDE
NEUTRAL EXPERT TESTIMONY OR TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. ON THE AUDIT THE LEAD TO
THIS BILL IS BOB HARRIS WHO'S A
PRINCIPAL AUDITOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE. WELL YES HERE OKAY
GREAT SO WITH THAT. I DíAS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
THANK SENATOR- MR- MISTER.
JEREMY BERNIE RIGHT YES SO TO
SPEAK THE PLEASE REMEMBER THAT
MY NAME IS ABOUT. WITH ACCOUNT
STATE ON OFF- AS A MATTER
MATTER POLICY ARE DOESN'T A
FORM POSITION ON BILLS BUT CAN
PROVIDE SOME TEST MY AS TO HOW
AS FIFTY EIGHT WITH A RECKON.
WE'VE MADE IN PRIOR AUDITS
BRIEFLY AS THIS IS ALREADY
MENTIONED AND BUT IT'S THAT
WE'VE RELEASED REVIEWING
PRACTICES OF YOU AN APPLY
SOCIAL SECURITY NOW TO THAT
IT'S OUT TO ITS CLAIM AND WE
THAT IT DOES SO VERY FREAKED
WITH MY OF ITS MAY. AND DOES SO
OF PRE WE RECOMMENDED THAT PER
IN FACT WE WRECKED THEY PER.
THE THREE MOST COMMONLY MAILED
FORMS WHICH IS THE- WHICH OF
THE FORMS OF THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS AND THAT WE RECOMMENDED
THEY SEIZE CEASE INCLUDING THE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS ON
THOSE FORMS BY MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY BUT OUR FOR A FOLLOW UP
ON IT BUT WE RELEASED IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY FIVE EDT
HAD NOT MADE SUFFICIENT
PROGRESS ON THAT. AND AS A
RESULT DURING THE PANDEMIC HAD
MAILED THOSE THREE FORMS ALONE
THIRTY FOUR MILLION TIMES JUST
FROM MARCH TO OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY. SO THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE EDT TO TAKE ACTION ON
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'VE MADE
THAT IT HAS NOT YET MADE
SUFFICIENT PROGRESS ON AND WITH.
THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
OF THE COMMITTEES QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OF WHO
WE- REMEMBER A COMMITTEE.
SENATOR- YES- CENTER I'M WILL
BE SOME YOUR BILL- JUST HAVE A
FOR THE AUDITOR. US FOODS IS
THE ORDER. I JUST REMEMBER TO
GO PLEASE YOU YOU MAN THAT-
THERE WITH OF THREE FOR TYPES
OF COME. AND WHICH SUCH THE
NUMBERS HAD BEEN INCLUDED- I'M
JUST WONDERING DID YOU LOOK
INTO WHETHER OR NOT THEY- THAT
PRACTICE LEAD TO ANY OF FRAUD
OR IDENTITY IDENTITY IDENTITY
THEFT. RIGHT- BECAUSE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT. FROM THE
HEARINGS THAT WE'VE HAD THAT
THE- FRAUD WAS MORE CONNECTED
TO OTHER ISSUES AND NOT THIS
ONE BUT CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT
CONNECTION FOR SWIMMING NO
FINDING THAT THERE WAS A DIRECT
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE MAILINGS
THAT EDT SENDS OUT AND
SOMEONE'S IDENTITY BEING STOLEN
AND THAT WOULD BE PRETTY
DIFFICULT TO DO. BUT WHAT IT
DOES DO WHEN YOU MAIL OUT SOME
OF SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER THAT
THAT IS A PUTS IT UNNECESSARILY
AT RISK AND AS WE SAW DURING
THE PANDEMIC PERIOD MAIL IS
SHOWING UP TO PEOPLE'S
ADDRESSES WHERE IT DIDN'T
BELONG AND SOME OF THAT MAIL WE
FOUND IN OUR FOLLOW BUT
INCLUDED INDIVIDUAL SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS SO IN FACT YOU
HAVE IS. ESSENTIALLY A BREACH
OF THAT PERSON'S PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION GOING
TO SOME PLACE WHERE IT DOESN'T
BELONG BEING RECEIVED BY
SOMEONE THAT SHOULD NOT HAPPEN.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU YEAH I WAS
ASKING NOT BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD BE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE OF THE CHANGE BUT
BECAUSE I I'D IT'S PUT OUT
THERE BUT NOT NECESSARILY
ALWAYS A STRAIGHT STRAIGHT
CONNECTION SPECIALLY TO THE
FRAUD THAT WE'VE HEARD SO MUCH
ABOUT. THANK YOU. ANY BUT ALSO
QUESTIONS OF THE WITNESS FROM
THE COMMITTEE WE MOVE ON TO.
OTHER THANK YOU- WELL IT'S A
BEGIN WITHOUT ANY WOODEN HERE
IN ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ARE THERE ANY. A
SEEN NONE THE WILL MOVE ON TO-
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WAS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY EIGHT. THE SERVER.
I SEE NONE THE WOLF- OF THE S.
CURVE. SO I'M SORRY THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER- WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WOULD
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WE THE TEST
POINTS TO. OF S. FIFTY EIGHT WE
CAN BEGIN. AS A REMINDER YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE. UNIONIST INDICATION
BEEN PLACED INTO Q. AND IN
EIGHTEEN SPECIALS WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH A LINE NUMBER. WHEN WE
CALL YOUR LINE OF PLEASE STAY
YOUR NAME FOR THE- RIGHT. THANK
ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR FIRST
QUESTION. WE HAVE A QUESTION
FROM THE LINE OF FROM NINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TOM SHE HE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT TODAY AND WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE
FORWARD. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE CUED UP. OKAY
THANK YOU. THE MODERATOR P.
PREACHER GOING ONCE AGAIN TO BE
SURE WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORT WITNESSES ON SB. FIFTY
EIGHT. THANK AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO
HAVE A QUESTION OR COMMENT.
PLEASE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
NOW TO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCHTONE FONG. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME. THE WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE KNOWN HERE
ANY OPPOSITION ARE THERE- ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO- IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. C. NONE HOST
ONE WITNESSES IN ROOM TH.
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY OFFICES OF S. B. EIGHT.
C. NONE- WE'RE NOW GONNA MOVE
ON TO BUT WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR PETE PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WE INTO
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION OF SB
FIFTY EIGHT WE CAN BEGIN.
YOU'RE SPEAKING OPPOSITE OF SB
FIFTY A PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP. THANK YOU
MODERATE FUTURE TO ONE ONCE
AGAIN BEACH REFERRED FROM ALL
ANY AND ALL OPPOSITION. AS A
REMINDER IF YOU'RE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
NO INCLUDED TIME. ALL RIGHTS
YOU MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE PUSH
OR COMMENTS. THIS NEWMAN- THANK
YOU MISTER SO CENTER WORLDS
TOTO BUT YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL IS DESK NEEDED BIT OF
SENSE IS A REAL TO PRIVACY I
COMMEND YOU AND I WOULD AT RISK
BEING POLITICAL AUTHOR IS BILL
MOVES FOR YEAH WILL BE AMENDING
IT AND SHE DID SO WILL WITH
TIME YOU. TO THE COMMENTS ARE.
FROM MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE. THE
C. NINE MONTHS WHAT COULD YOU
TO CLOSE UP HALF OF ITS HER
TADO ASPIRIN VOTE. MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE JUDICIARY
CENTER KRITISIERT DIE UNTER
COURTESY FIVE. IN ORDER TO SHOW
BOTH HI AND DINNER TRAVEL BOOK
BY SENATOR RAZA. IN ORDER
RESIDENTS HI CENTER EARLIER BY-
LAYERED BY CENTER NEWMAN. SIR
NEWMAN HI. ZERO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE SECURING MEMBERS.
WELCOME SENATOR HER TOTAL YOU
MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL SB. SIXTY
ONE. REVENUE IN MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START
OFF BY CONGRATULATING OF.
CENTER CORTES YANIS
CHAIRMANSHIP OF THIS COMMITTEE-
I'M HERE TODAY TO REPRESENT SB
SIXTY ONE WHICH HELPS
UNEMPLOYED AND UNDEREMPLOYED
INDIVIDUALS ACCESSING COMPLETE
JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS THROUGH
PROVIDING SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
SB SIXTY ONE IS A RIGHT
INVESTMENT FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AS OUR MOST
VULNERABLE ARE IN DANGER OF
BEING PULLED FARTHER AWAY FROM
ACHIEVING THEIR AMERICAN DREAM.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO LIFT. UP
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS BY
PROVIDING SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
TO THEM WHILE THEY WORK TO
COMPLETE WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS. THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THE BOARD TO DEVELOP
ADDITIONAL EMPLOYMENT
PARTNERSHIPS TO ADDRESS
DISPLACEMENT OF WORKERS. IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY INCLUDING
FARMWORKERS AND DISCONNECTED AT
RISK AT RISK YOUTH IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE PROACTIVELY
ADDRESS UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND PARTICULARLY IN
THE ROLE CENTRAL VALLEY MANY
WORKFORCE TRAINING PARTICIPANTS
ARE UNABLE TO COMPLETE THEIR
JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS DUE TO A
LACK OF AFFORDABLE
TRANSPORTATION OR AFFORDABLE
CHILDCARE. SB SIXTY ONE WILL
HELP PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
ASSISTANCE TO UNEMPLOYED AND
UNDEREMPLOYED WORKERS THAT ARE
PURSUING OR WOULD LIKE TO
PURSUE WORKFORCE TRAINING. BUT
HAVE REAL LIFE CHALLENGES
STANDING IN THEIR WAY. THIS
MEASURE IS NEEDED NOW MORE THAN
EVER TO IMPROVE THE ABILITY. OF
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS TO PUT
TO MAKE PROGRESS IN THEIR
CAREERS AND DOING SO WILL HAVE
A FOUNDATIONAL IMPACT ON
DISRUPTING MULTI GENERATIONAL
POVERTY. I HAVE A TWO DAY THREE
WITNESSES WHO ARE JOINING US
REMOTELY. AND I WILL LET THEM
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES. THANK YOU
SENATOR HER DAUGHTER. WE HAVE
THE FIRST WITNESS INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES. I'M GONNA AYE
KALISH- THANK YOU CHAIR OF THE
STATE'S CHILD POVERTY TASK
FORCE. A MAN I CONTINUE YES
PLEASE. OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THE FIRST THANKS TO
SENATOR TITLE FOR STICKING WITH
THIS- IMPORTANT BILL AT THE END
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE STATE
CHILD POVERTY TASK FORCE ISSUED
ITS COMPREHENSIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS ELIMINATING
DEEP CHILD POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA AND REDUCING ITS
OVERALL BY AT LEAST FIFTY
PERCENT. THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM IS
CALLED THE COMPREHENSIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE FRAMEWORK
FOR CALIFORNIA'S FOUR POINT
EIGHT BILLION IN ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN ADDRESSING CHILD
FAMILY POVERTY SINCE THAT TIME
A KEY ASPECT WAS STRENGTHENING-
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS OF
THE WORK FORCE TRAINING-
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE TASK FORCE
WAS CHAIRED BY THE POLICY AND
RESEARCH DIRECTOR. OF THE STATE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND
THEY WERE TASKED WITH
INVESTIGATING EXISTING
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS AND POLICIES
THEY FOUND THAT THE PRIMARY
REASON LOW INCOME PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS WERE NOT ABLE TO
COMPLETE PROGRAMS. WERE
UNRELIABLE CHILD CARE THE LACK
OF AFFORDABLE TRANSPORTATION
AND. OTHER SUPPORTS LIKE SECURE
HOUSING- THIS. AND STOPS THE
HOLD FORCE. EMPHASIZED THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT COULD BE DONE IN THE WORK
FORCE AND TRAINING AREA IS TO
REMOVE THE BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATION AND COMPLETION OF
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS BY
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDING
DISCONNECTED YOUTH. AND
DISPLACED WORKERS INCLUDING
THOSE WORKING IN AGRICULTURE BY
PROVIDING DEDICATED FUNDING FOR
CHILDCARE TRANSPORTATION AND
OTHER SUPPORTS LIKE HOUSING.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS PEOPLE HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO GET TO AND FROM
WORK I HAVE TO HAVE A RELIABLE
CHILD CARE HOUSING SECURITY AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE. IT'S THE MISSING
LINK IN MAXIMIZING THE
EFFECTIVENESS BUT WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND WE ARE
CHEN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER HALL MR CALLS. THE
NEXT WITNESS IDENTIFY. HIS OR
HERSELF PLEASE. I UNDERSTAND WE
MAY HAVE A TRANSLATOR FOR ONE
THE WITNESSES CENTER YES SO WE
SHOULD HAVE ALL MY OF SHANKER
AT. THE TESTIFYING TODAY AND I
BELIEVE THAT. THE INDIVIDUAL-
TRANSLATING FOR HER WAS NOT
ABLE TO MAKE IT- I'M NOT SURE
IF ALMOST ON THE CALL. XOMA ON
THE CALL. TESTING. THE OLDEST
ALL ALMOST. YEAH JUST PUTTING
THOSE STARKEY OKAY NO OKAY. SHE
COMING. EIGHTEEN PROBABLY NOT
AT THIS POINT OKAY I CAN WRAP
UP. FOR HIS. WELL LET ME LET ME
COME BACK TO SENATOR TOTAL LET
ME- CHECK WITH THEM TO SEE WHAT
OTHER WITNESSES WE HAVE BESIDES
THE IDENTIFIED WITNESSES-
BEFORE WE MOVE ON THEY'LL COME
BACK TO THIS- TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU. OKAY SO OFTEN NEXT ON TO
JUST TO DOUBLE CHECK YOUR WRIST
WITH A NO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES- IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
SIXTY ONE. SEEN NONE OF OUR TO
THE OVERFLOW ROOM TWENTY
FORTIES OR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
ONE. THE SCENE NO ONE NO ONE
THERE. I WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR TO PLEASE PROPERTY
OFFICIALS WE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY ONE. WE CAN
BEGIN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU HAVE. A COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIXTY ONE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN EIGHTEEN
TWO SPECIALS WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. PLEASE
MAKE CERTAIN THAT YOUR PHONE IS
ON MUTE IT BEFORE YOU PRESS ANY
BUTTONS. AND MAKE CERTAIN THAT
YOUR- RESUME MEETING DEVICE IS
MUTED. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE
HAVE QUESTIONS COMING UP AT
THIS TIME. THE MOTOR IF YOU
PLEASE LET US KNOW THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IF WE HAVE THREE AND
FIRST WE WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY
SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE. THIS IS
JENNIFER WILLIAMS CUT THE EAST
BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT
AND THE COURT. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE HOLD PLEASE
WHILE WE SECURE YES ONE MORE WE
SECURE THE LINE NUMBER FOR THAT
ONE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN THE COURT.
THANK YOU IT WILL GO TO AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY THREE.
ONE MOMENT. MY TWENTY THREE
YEAR OUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JACKIE TOO LONG LONG ON THE V.
P. OF TALKING AFTER THE
PROGRESS AND BALL AT THE END
CHILD POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA.
COALITION REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS- AND NOT ACROSS
THE STATE- AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA HOW CAN USE NETWORK-
WE ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS
BILL AND. HERS AND I ABOUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
MOTOR IF YOU PLEASE CHECK THE
ONE WHICH CAN BE SURE WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORT WAS
WITNESSES ON SB SIXTY ONE. IF
ANYONE ELSE IS SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY ONE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY NOW TO PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN KID AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU BUT WE'LL
MOVE ON OPPOSITION WITNESSES
SO- ARE THERE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES SO HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. C. NONE OTHER
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY. C. NONE.
WHO WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIXTY ONE- WE CAN BEGIN AND-
WILL ASK YOU TO TAKE THEM
INDIVIDUALLY. BAKER LED INTO
MEDICARE AND IF YOU ARE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIXTY ONE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP FOR
OPPOSITION. MARTYRDOM IS SAYS
HE TO ONCE AGAIN BE SURE WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL POSITION
WITNESSES SAID- MAYBE TRYING TO
GET ONTO THE TOTAL CORPORATE
SERVICE. YES WHAT ONCE AGAIN IF
WE ARE THERE AS OPPOSITION THE
TO SB SIXTY ONE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. GERMAN WAY
OF KNOWING QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR- WILL
KNOW- BRING BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CENTER DRAWS OF.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR ON BRINGING THIS- FORWARD-
I IN MY EXPERIENCE IN THE WITH
TRAINING PROGRAMS. NO DOUBT
THAT LOW INCOME WORKERS-
BENEFIT THE MOST- WHEN THEY
HAVE THE- TRAINING THAT THEY
NEED. ESPECIALLY IF THE PROGRAM
IS REALLY TARGETING NOT JUST
SORT OF GENERALLY WHOEVER SHOWS
UP BUT REALLY TARGETED- AND I
KNOW THAT WITHOUT- THE SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED- THAT IT'S IT
BECOMES THANK YOU RAIMES
IMPOSSIBLE- SO I THINK THAT'S
REALLY GREAT. THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING FORWARD PROVIDING
THOSE- I ALSO SEE THE- THAT THE
PREMISE OF THE HIGHROAD
PARTNERSHIPS. IS A PIECE OF
THIS AND I'M I'M REALLY
THRILLED WITH THAT BECAUSE I'VE
ALSO FOUND THAT THERE HAD BEEN
THESE TRAINING PROGRAMS IN MY
EXPERIENCE. THAT DID THE
TRAINING AND SOMETIMES DID
SERVICES SOMETIMES DIDN'T BUT
THEN AT THE END COULDN'T
DELIVER A QUALITY JOB. AND SO
HERE THEY WERE BACK IN A
DIFFERENT INDUSTRY. MAY BE. AT
MINIMUM WAGE AND NO BENEFITS
AND NO YOU KNOW NOTHING REALLY
TO LOOK FORWARD TO IN THEIR
LIVES SO. I REALLY LIKE THAT A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN EMPLOYERS
AND WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO GET
TO A QUALITY PAID JOB IS. IS
ESSENTIAL SO ANOTHER QUESTION
JUST COMMEND YOU AND UNLESS YOU
HAVE SOMETHING ELSE TO SAY
ALONG THOSE LINES BUT I THINK
ALL THOSE ELEMENTS MAKE THIS. A
GOOD INVESTMENT THANK YOU.
THANK ANY. DISCUSS THIS CHAU
CHAVEZ. HI HELLO OUR DISTRICT-
IT'S MANAGED THAT IN PREVIOUS
YEARS WHEN THIS BILL WAS PASSED
THAT THERE WAS A CAP ON THE
GRANT PER RECIPIENT BY ANDERSON
AND THIS ONE DOES NOT HAVE A
CAP IS YOUR REASON FOR THAT.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR BOB. SO IF THE
CAP WAS REMOVED BECAUSE OF
NECESSARY SUPPORTS IN THE COST
OF THE SUPPORTS WILL BE
DIFFERENT IN DIFFERENT REGIONS
SO THAT THE SUPPORT SO WE GET
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY PERHAPS
ARE NOT THE SAME COSTS THAT YOU
WOULD GET LIKE YOU KNOW IN SAN
FRANCISCO OR SACRAMENTO. AND SO
THAT THERE'S GOT TO BE GET WE
GOT HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF THAT
FLEXIBILITY THEY'RE PERFECTLY
FINE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL IT'S
NOT A ONE TIME BUDGET I ALWAYS
SAY IT OKAY THAT MAKES ABSOLUTE
SENSE THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THAT- THE OTHER QUESTION I HAD-
THIS BILL ARM IS EXTENDED FROM
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES
ACT THE APA. OUR WHICH ALLOWS
FOR PUBLIC INPUT AND SCRUTINY-
JUST KIND OF CURIOUS TO KNOW
WHY IT WAS EXCLUDED FROM THAT.
TEMPERAMENT. SO IT SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE STREAMLINED
GETTING THESE GRANTS TO THE
COMMUNITIES AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
WITH THE URGENCY IT IS THERE-
AND IN PART- NOW MORE THAN EVER
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC WE NEED
TO. THAT'S WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO.
AT THE EXEMPTION AND THEREFORE
THERE FOR THOSE PURPOSES. SO
WOULD THERE BE A SAFETY OR
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THESE FUNDS
IF. MOVING FORWARD. I WOULD SAY
SO- AND I CAN PROVIDE YOU WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION MOVING
FORWARD ON HOW THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY- IT'S BEING
MADE- BUT WHAT I WILL SAY IS
THAT THE AP WHAT THE LADY. OUR
WHAT DELAY GETTING THESE GRANTS
TO THE COMMUNITIES- TO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED IT THE
MOST OF THE TIME WHEN. THANK
GOD THEY NEED THE MOST IT. YEAH
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING
AT THE MOMENT AND NEED TO FIND
A WAY TO GET BACK INTO THE
WORKFORCE. AND ONE LAST
QUESTION SO HELP ME UNDERSTAND
SO MOVING FORWARD IS THAT WITH
THIS IS AND I UNDERSTAND THE
STREAMLINING PART BECAUSE I.
DON'T CARE FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
RED TAPE AND LENGTHENING THE
PROCESS AND MANY OF THE ITEMS
AND ISSUES BUT I DO BELIEVE IN
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
OF COURSE- SO IS THIS WOULD BE
WOULD THIS BE TEMPORARILY RIGHT
NOW IT AS WE'RE GOING THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC AND- WE'RE DEALING
WITH A WITH THE ISSUES DUE TO
THE- SHUT DOWN AND SO FORTH. SO
SB SIXTY- AND IT'S ALSO- IT
GOES ALONG WITH THE BUDGET
REQUEST A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THE BUDGET PROCESS
FOR THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
CHANCE IT'S A ONE WAY OF.
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE DOLLARS
ARE BEING USED IN THE WAY THAT
DATE. THIRTY SHOULD BE USED.
BUT I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT THE-
THE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. BOARDS TO. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR. IF YOU'LL FOR
SURE TWO WILL. TAKE YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION BY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THE C. NINE
SENATORS RICARDO JOIN CLOSE. AT
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS IN THE SUPPORT- AND
THE QUESTIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU WE HAVE
MOTION AND SB SIXTY ONE. MOVED
BY SENATOR DRAW SO- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANTS CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTIONS THE PAST
TWO APPROPRIATIONS CENTER
COURTESY. OF THE- SENATOR-
CHILDREN. SORRY DO YOU HAVE ONE
MORE TIME PLEASE. I THANK YOU
CENTER OPAL CHIU ABOVE BY
CENTER DRAWS A LINE. UNDER
DORADO BY SEN EARLIER HI DINNER
LAYERED FIVE CENTER NEWMAN HI
THERE NEWMAN. FIVE ZERO. THANK
YOU BILLS OUT. WELCOME CENTER
MCGUIRE I THINK THIS. YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL SB TWO OH SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE- MISTER CONSULTANT
VERY GRATEFUL THAT TO BE WITH
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU FIRST
OF ALL MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
SAY HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE TO YOU
INTO YOUR VERY CAPABLE STAFF
FOR THE WORK AND ENGAGEMENT ON
SENATE BILL TWO OH SIX. WHICH
IS FOCUS ON EQUAL PROTECTIONS
FOR SEASONAL CAL FIRE
FIREFIGHTERS THIS IS REALLY A
PARITY BILL AS CALIFORNIA FACES
LONGER FIRE SEASONS EVERY YEAR
THE LARGEST AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY
WILDFIRES IN THE GOLDEN STATE
HISTORY HAVE CRIPPLED
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST
DECADE. AND IT'S BEEN CRYSTAL
CLEAR IT'S BEEN CRYSTAL CLEAR
THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS SHOULD HAVE EQUAL
PROTECTIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
THE JOB REGARDLESS OF THEIR
EMPLOYMENT STATUS WITH THE
AGENCY FULL TIME OR SEASONAL IF
YOU'RE A FULL TIME OR SEASONAL
FIREFIGHTER YOUR LIFE IS ON THE
LINE FIGHTING FIRE IN
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES.
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS MAY ONLY
SERVE UP TO NINE MONTHS PER
YEAR WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
RANKS DUE TO THEIR TEMPORARY
CLASSIFICATION IN MANY SEASONAL
FIREFIGHTERS WORKED SEASONALLY
FOR MULTIPLE YEARS SOMETIMES
UP. TO A DECADE OR MORE NOW
THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER FOUR
MILLION ACRES OF CALIFORNIA
LAND BURNED IN TWENTY TWENTY
ALONE DUE TO DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES AS THE THREATS HAVE
BECOME INCREASINGLY COMMON THE
STATE DEPENDS NOW MORE AND MORE
ON SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS WITH
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY HIGHER
THAN TWENTY TWENTY AN
ADDITIONAL THAT ARE PLANNING TO
BE HIRED. SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
IN THE GOVERNOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET PROPOSAL. SB TWO OH
SIX IT'S A SIMPLE BILL DECEMBER
BILL BECAUSE IT PROVIDES. EQUAL
PROTECTION FOR EQUAL WORK. IT
ALLOWS TIMBER IN C. FIRE. TO BE%
INCLUDED IN THE PROTECTIONS IN
THE FIREFIGHTERS BILL OF RIGHTS
THAT WAS PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. NOW THE BILL OF
RIGHTS GRANTS FIREFIGHTERS THE
SAME JOB PROTECTIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE ACCESS TO FULL AND FAIR
APPEAL PROCESS AFTER BEING
TERMINATED PROTECTION FROM
UNREASONABLE INTERROGATION
PROTECTION FROM UNWANTED OR
UNWARRANTED SEARCHES OF THEIR
PERSONAL PROPERTY. SEASONAL
FIREFIGHTERS LET'S JUST BE
BLUNT. ON THE FRONT LINE THE
PROTECTING OUR HOMES OUR
PARTICULAR FAMILIES FROM THE
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES CONTINUE
TO RAVAGE THE STATE. AND IT'S
PAST TIME FOR THE STATE TO
PROTECT THEM. AS MUCH AS THEY
PROTECT US. THE COMMITTEE HAS
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS
CLARIFYING THAT INMATE
FIREFIGHTERS ARE NOT COVERED BY
THE FAR FAR BILL RIGHT. AND
OBVIOUSLY WE WILL GLADLY BE
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
MCGINNIS RICHARD THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ENGAGEMENT. AT THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY CAL FIRE. LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHTY ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS MISTER CHAIR I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY TIM EDWARDS
PRESIDENT OF CAL FIRE LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE. AS
WELL AS CHRISTY BOMA
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AT
THE RIGHT TIME THE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE IN THIS IS.
NOT SUPPORTED ALSO BY BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ALIKE
THANK YOU SO MUCH RESEARCHER.
THE FIX AND REQUIRE- WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD MOVE ON NOW
TO- TESTIMONY. IN A BELIEF-
CENTER CAN YOU IDENTIFY AGAIN
THE FIRST WITNESS. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE THE
PRESIDENT OF LOCAL TWENTY
EIGHT. EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY ONE REPRESENTING
ALL CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS
PRESIDENT TIM EDWARDS WITH US.
MR. EDWARDS SILVA. HIS PRESENT.
THROUGH TELECONFERENCE. BUT
HE'S TO BE ON THE LAW ONLINE
THANK YOU. MISTER EDWARDS IF
YOU CAN HEAR ME YOU MAY. CHECK.
MISTER EDWARDS IS NOT PRESENT.
LET'S MOVE ON TO A AND M'S
PALMA CHRISTI BOMA AND THEN
WE'LL COME BACK AND SEE IF YOU
MISTER EDWARDS IS PRESENT AFTER.
CHRISTIE BEAUMONT'S TESTIMONIES
CRITICAL AVAILABLE. YES THERE
PLEASE PROCEED WHAT THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO CHRISTINE- ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS THE
BEGINNING MORE THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND CAREER FIREFIGHTING
AND EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICE.
THANK Y. SPONSORED OF THE RING
BILL. ASSEMBLY FIREFIGHTER
DAUGHTER OUT RIGHT PROBABLY
WITH SPEAKER- KEREN **** FAIRLY.
ANALYST PROCESS FOR
CONGRESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS MAY
BE SUBJECT GOING. FIREFIGHTERS
TO WORK NINE MONTHS OUT OF THE
YEAR CLEVELAND SEASON. CAREER
PATTERNS MUST YOUR FAILURES.
YES YOU WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
SIGNAL CARD FRAZIER HAS TRAINED
AND THEY'RE AN INTEGRAL PART
CAL FIREFIGHTING FORCE. SYSTEM
IS UPDATED IN YOUR- TIME WHEN
CAN GO BY ARE NOT GOING TO GO
COULD ON THE THEY ARE TO. THE
BILL WITH REQUIRE ANYTHING
EXCEPT THAT ON AMERICAN WHEN A
PAYER DISCIPLINE FIREFIGHTER BE
GIVEN EVIDENCE HEARING AND DUE
PROCESS. PROBABLY THEIR OWN
RECOURSE IS MEETING USERS OF
THE CUT OF DIFFICULT NUMBER
PERFECTLY. OKAY I'M RIGHT HAVE
THEIR VIEW HEARD BY THIRD PARTY.
UNDER TERRIBLE FOR YEARS WOULD
SEEM TO FIREFIGHTERS AND THEN
ADD. TO EVACUATE WORKS FULL
TIME WITH PEOPLE. WITH THE
LOCAL OVERDUE. I THINK F.
REPORT CAL. FIVE ART
FIREFIGHTER NOW. WHEN I LOOKED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FORMER. OF
THE SEVEN. SENATE MCGUIRE ROOM
IDENTIFY MR EARLY MISTER WILL
ON THE AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE CUTER AS A QUESTION ONE
MOMENT ALL HIS LIFE. OKAY THANK
YOU THIS REDWOOD JULY WAS OPEN.
YEAH CARE ME YES PLEASE. TRYING
TO MAKE SURE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
YOU MY NAME IS TIM WORK FOR
THEM CAL FIRE LOOK. TWENTY
EIGHTY ONE STANDING IN STRONG
OF AT THE OKAY. ARBOR APART.
ONE MISTER MISTER EDWARDS OF
CAN HEAR ME WE JUST SAW YOUR
ALL. NO RIGHT TO HAVE IT IN
HEARING THIS CLEAN UP ON
FIREFIGHT BILL RIGHT KALAU IN
THERE A FULL. HEARING IT'S LIKE
EVERY OTHER TIMES. IN K.
LIFELONG. FULL TIME BY. FOR
NINETY IN MORE SOMETIME. AND IS
THERE THE RIGHT CAN AN INJURY
HEARING. BUT CAN. THAT THERE
BROUGHT BACK TO THE WHEN THEY
CAN JUST BE OFF AT THE WHIM OF
THE CAPTAIN. IS DISAPPOINTED
WITH ONE. WE STAND STRONG
SUPPORT IN ECHO THE WORDS-
CANADA MCGUIRE INCREASE THE
BALLOT SEPIA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IN ITS VERY SMALL CAP IN
NON MISTER RECESSED. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE- NEED ANY OF THAT
REPEATED OR- WE'RE GOOD I'M C.
NODDING OF HEADS SO WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON- LET'S NOW BEGIN
WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ARE THERE- ANY
WITNESSES- IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB TWO OH SIX. THE
SCENE NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES- IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO OH SIX. YO SEE
NONE. BUT WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
THE TELECONFERENCE ARVEST
MODERATOR P. BEGIN. POLICE TO
PROFITABLE WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO OH SIX
WE CAN BEGIN AN IDEA SAID TO
CALL THEM INDIVIDUALLY.
ABSOLUTELY AND AGAIN IF YOU
HAVE A SUPPORT IN SB TWO ZERO
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN WE DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
PHONE IS NOT MUTED BEFORE
PRESSING ANY BUTTONS AND TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT YOUR- DEVICE
THAT YOUR LISTING ON ZOOM. IT'S
ALSO MUTED. WE DO HAVE ONE LINE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GET THE INFORMATION.
WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY WE ARE
GOING TO LINE FIFTEEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. FURTHER DIGITAL OF
WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE MISTER
MODERATOR. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE NOWHERE ELSE COULD UP AT
THIS TIME IT COULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES ONE MORE TIME-
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL THE SUPPORT WHEN THIS
IS ON S. B. TWO OH SIX.
PERMITTED TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO REMIND
PARTICIPANTS IF YOU ARE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
ZERO SIX. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO INCLUDE
OF MISTER CHAIRMAN ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MR MURRAY WILL NOW
MOVE TO- ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ARE THERE ANY-
WITNESSES HERE IN OPPOSITION IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. PLEASE COME
FORWARD SEEN NONE. WILL MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES AND ROOM FOR TWO
OR THREE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
TWO OH SIX. OH SEE NONE. MISTER
MODERATOR- WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
TO HEAR FROM INDIVIDUALS GOING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION S. B.
TWO OH SIX IF THERE ARE ANY.
AND IF SO CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THEM INDIVIDUALLY. THE LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF ANYONE IS
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO ZERO SIX PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED
UP. THANK YOU COULD YOU PLEASE-
ANNOUNCER ONE MORE TIME TO OPEN
UP THE LINES AND CALL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES BEFORE WE
MOVE ON. YES SIR. AGAIN IF
THEIR OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO
S. B. TWO ZERO SIX PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCHTONE
PHONE AT THIS TIME. FIFTY
BERMAN WHO HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
WITH TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND TAKE YOU TO THE
WITNESSES WHO DID TESTIFY ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
DISCUSSION BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE CENTER LAYERED-
FIRST I WOULD MOVE THE BILL.
AND THEN I HAVE A COMMENT
STORIES- OF BILL IS THE MOTION
IS MADE BY SENATOR LAYERED BACK
CENTER ALERT PERFORMANCE ON THE
MOTION. THEIR WIVES AND.
WELCOME BACK TO A CENTER
LAYERED AFTER THE DISCUSSION
FOR THE MOTION- FIVE I'VE
SIGNALED AN INTENT. A IT WILL
BE RECOGNIZE NOW THAT YOUR
COMMENTS YEAH AND I HAVE A
FEELING WE ALL KNOW HOW WE'RE
GOING TO VOTE AFTER THE
SPEECHES. OF LET ME JUST SAY I
WAS A MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN WHEN WE
ENACTED THE FIRST FIVE
FIREFIGHTER BILL OF RIGHTS AS A
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAREN BASS
WAS THE AUTHOR. AND THERE WERE
A LOT OF THINGS SAID ABOT WHY.
IT MIGHT NOT WORK BUT THOSE
HAVE PROVED TO BE WRONG AND-
OF. OUR WILL BY THEN HAD. A
CHARGE OF CALIFORNIA FOR EIGHT
YEARS AS RESOURCES SECRETARY.
AND I THINK IT WAS A VALUABLE
PART OF OUR LABOR RELATIONS OUR
PROGRAM TO BE ABLE TO. MAKE
SURE FIREFIGHTERS WERE PUTTING
THEMSELVES FOR US. OUT FOR US
REALLY HAD THE RIGHTS TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES THE ISSUE WITH THIS
BILL WHICH IS GOING TO BE
INTERESTING OVER TIME. IS THAT
SINCE WE HAVE STARTED TO HAVE A
FIRE SEASON THAT NEVER ENDS.
THE TEMPORARY NATURE OF THESE
POSITIONS OF NINE MONTHS HAS
BEEN SUCH THAT THE FIRE SEASON
HAS STARTED TO. EXTEND PAST THE
TIME THAT THEY ARE SUPPOSEDLY
TEMPORARY WORKERS. AND SO I
THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY GOOD
MEASURE. BECAUSE IT STARTS TO
PUT IN PLACE THE RIGHTS AND THE
PROCEDURES FOR PEOPLE TO
OPERATE WHEN THEY START TO
BROUGHT UP AGAINST THAT. AND I
THINK WE WERE AS A GROUP OF
GOING TO HAVE A REAL DECISION
TO MAKE AT SOME POINT. ABOUT
WHETHER WE WANT TO HAVE MORE
PERMANENT FIREFIGHTERS IN LIEU
OF SEASONAL WORKERS IF WE HAVE-
FIRE SEASON THAT JUST GOES
TWELVE MONTHS A YEAR. END AND
THERE IS NO BREAK SO I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD BILL I'M GONNA
BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT. WILL BE
THRILLED TO MOVE IT WHEN I
FINALLY GET THE CHANCE. THEY
SHOULD OF- GIVEN THE-
OPPORTUNITY FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND OF COURSE WE GOT
TO GO- WILL NEED TO GO BACK
CENTER MCGUIRE FROM OPENING TO
CLOSE OF. PLEASURE TO A BOOK
FOR YOU YES PLEASE- RECOGNITION.
HER MCGUIRE- JUST TO CLEAR. AB
WILL YOU BE TAKING ALL OF THE
M. THAT WERE PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE. WE'RE TAKING THE MAY-
THE RECORD LIMITS CLARA THAT
THE IN THE INMATE. ARE NOT
COVERED BY THE FIRE BILL RIGHTS
THAT DOES AN MEANS THAT PER THE
DISCUSSION PLEASE CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG MISTER CHAIR THOSE
AMENDMENTS WOULD BE TAKEN IN
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
OKAY WHAT ABOUT THE- THE ITEM
WEIGHT WITH REGARDS TO THE
SECOND YEAR OF HIGHER FOR
TEMPORARY. CAL FIREFIGHTER
FIRES. MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE
ONLY AMENDMENTS THAT ARE ON THE
TABLE TODAY THAT- WE'VE COME TO
A MUTUAL AGREEMENT ON IS THE
ISSUE OF THE- INMATE
FIREFIGHTER LANGUAGE NOT BEING
COVERED BY THE FAR FAR BILL
RIGHTS. BUT A PLEASE CONSIDER
CORRECT ME IF YOU THINK ON A
MISTAKEN THAT. THIS MIGHT DOES
MUCH UNDERSTANDING AND YES. OR
INTEND TO BE TAKEN OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY THANK YOU.
ANYTHING ELSE FRAZIER M. ONE
LAST THING- WITH THIS BILL ALSO
BE- SEE. WOULD THIS BE APPLIED
RETROACTIVELY. IT'S GONNA BE
MOVING FORWARD. SO AFTER JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. LET ME
GET THE EXACT LANGUAGE WITHIN
THE BILL- MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
SHARE. VICE CHAIR I WILL HAVE
THAT FOR YOU MOMENTARILY.
COMEBACKER TO THE TO THE
QUESTION A MOMENT LET ME OF
CHECK TO SEE IF THERE IS ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO
WISH TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED
RECOGNIZED ON. THE C. NONE OF
THE SERVER CORPORATE TAKE YOUR
TIME IF YOU. WISH TO. THANK YOU.
I WILL BE BACK IN HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO GET BACK TO AND I
APOLOGIZE TO SECURE IF YOU LIKE
ME TO BE ABLE TO PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT I WILL GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT- BUT- WHAT I WILL SAY
FOR THE TIME BEING- IS SAID
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO OUR CO
AUTHORS ARE CO AUTHORS. OF A
SIMILAR FLOOR- THE SENATOR
LIMóN- AS WELL SO- D. AT THE
ACTION IN REGARDS TO THE EQUAL
PROTECTION FOR EQUAL WORK WILL
BE UPON TIME OF SIGNING. OF THE
BILL IF IT WERE TO MAKE IT TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK. SO
CANDIDLY THAT WOULD MEAN TIGHT
SINCE- WE WOULD BE BRINGING
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS ON COM-
JULY FIRST OFFICIALLY IN THE
NEW BUDGET YEAR IT WOULD TAKE
AFFECTED SINCE THE NEXT SEASON
NOW- WE MAY BE TAKING EARLY
ACTION ON FOR SOME SEASONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THIS YEAR THAT'S
TO BE DETERMINED BUT IT WOULD
BE A TIME A SIGNING OF THE BILL.
BUT THERE WOULD NOT BE ANY
RETROACTIVITY. THANK YOU FOR
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT IS TO RESEARCH AND VICE
CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
THANK YOU- MINIATURE WAS OR
ANYTHING ELSE BEFORE CENTER
REQUIRE RELEASE NUMBER SURE. OF
THAT SAID NO ONE ELSE HAD ASKED
TO BE RECOGNIZED- US SENATE
RECORD THINK YOU JUST CLOSED-
BUT IF YOU WAS SAYING LC MAY
EVER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME MISTER CHAIR RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU WILL COME BACK TO
SEVEN EARLIER NOW FOR MOTION.
THE BILL. RICHARDSON EARLIER IT
IS MOVE THE BILL- MOTIONS TO
PASS TO SENATE JUDICIARY- WAS
FOR ROLL CALL PLEASE. SENATE
QUARTERS. DIED IN A CAR. BY
SENATOR- MITCHELL. SKINNER-
CHILDREN HI CENTER DORADO HI IN
ORDER RESIDENTS HI CENTER
LAYERED HI AND- LAYERED BY
CENTER NEWMAN HI DINNER NEWMAN.
FIVE ZERO. THANK YOU OF THE
BILLS OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOU'RE THINKING MEMBERS TO GIVE.
SERVER YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL SB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT SINCE
WE HAVE THING SENATORS HERE.
WELCOME THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS MISTER CHAIR
WOULD IT BE OKAY IF I PRESENTED
MY OTHER BILL TO NINETY FOUR
AFTER THIS BILL I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE THEM IN THAT ORDER THANK
YOU WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH
A GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME TODAY SB TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT. PROTECTS THE PROMISED
AND PAID FOR RETIREMENT
BENEFITS OF CALPERS MEMBERS BY
MAKING SURE THAT NO HARM COMES
TO RETIREE FOR ANY COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED PENSIONABLE
COMPENSATION THAT WAS REPORTED
TO THE SYSTEM. THIS MEASURE
RESPONSE TO CASES IN WHICH
PENSION WILL COMPENSATION OF
RETIRED EMPLOYEES IS
RETROACTIVELY DEEMED DISALLOWED
BY CALPERS IN THESE INSTANCES
THE RETIRED EMPLOYEES ARE
FORCED TO PAY BACK A TOTAL OF
WERE OVERPAID AMOUNT AND SUFFER
PERMANENT REDUCTIONS IN THEIR
PENSIONS. BATTERY TOO MANY
RETIREES LIVE ON FIXED INCOMES
AND SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE UNEXPECTED CUTS TO
THEIR BENEFITS AT NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN LONG AFTER THEY HAVE
RETIRED FIFTY TO SEVENTY ACRES
MIND THAT THE RETIREMENT THAT
THEY EARNED AND PAID FOR. OVER
A LIFE OF PUBLIC SERVANTS WILL
CONSISTENTLY BE THERE
THROUGHOUT THEIR RETIREMENT
YEARS. THIS BILL REQUIRES
CALPERS AND EMPLOYERS TO WORK
TOGETHER TO PROTECT RETIREE
BENEFITS AND PREVENT THESE
INSTANCES FROM EVER HAPPENING
IN THE FIRST PLACE SB TWO
SEVENTY ALSO COMPELS EMPLOYERS
TO KEEP THEIR PROMISE TO
RETIREES AND HOLD THEM HARMLESS
FOR ANY REDUCTIONS TO THE
RETIREMENT AS A RESULT OF
DISALLOWED COMPENSATION. WITH
ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS DOUG SUPERS BUT THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS MEMBERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THERE WERE NO
TO MOVE ON TO ANYONE THOUGH
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN THE
CENTER LEAVE A- ON. YOUR
SUPPORT WITNESSES PRESENT
COMBINE ABILITIES CALLING IT
YES. ASSEMBLY THIS DOG SUPERS
IS THAT CORRECT YES RIGHT
MISTER SERVERS- IF YOU'RE
HEARING ME- PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS THIS IS A DOG SERVERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
REPRESENTING MORE THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND CAREER FIREFIGHTING
AND EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICE
PERSONNEL STATEWIDE WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AND SPONSOR
SB TWO SEVEN EIGHT ONE LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR LINDA FOR HER
ONGOING WORK TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT SECURITY FOR PUBLIC
SERVANTS. THIS ISSUE FIRST CAME
TO SERBIA WHEN A FIREFIGHTER
EMPLOYED BY THE CITY OF DAVIS
RETIRED AFTER SERVING THE
PUBLIC FOR NEARLY THIRTY YEARS
AFTER FIVE YEARS OF THE TYERMAN
CALPERS NOTIFIED THE RETIRED
FIREFIGHTER THAT THE CITY OF
DAVIS HAD REPORTED CERTAIN
COMPENSATION I CALPERS BELIEVED
WAS DISALLOWED. CONSEQUENTLY
THE SYSTEM SOUGHT TO COLLECT
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE
OVERPAYMENT NOT FROM THE CITY
THAT HAVE BARGAINED I REPORTED
TO GOSHEN COMPENSATION BUT
INSTEAD FROM THE RETIRED
FIREFIGHT. REIMBURSEMENTS ON
THE CALPERS INCLUDED A LUMP SUM
AMOUNT OF FORTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON A SIZEABLE FUTURE
REDUCTION IN THE RETIRED
FIREFIGHTERS. RETIREMENT
ALLOWANCE SBI'S CALLED ACADEMIC
BENEFIT THAT WAS COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED AND PAID FOR BY THE
EMPLOYEE AND THE EMPLOYER LIKE
MANY RETIREES ONE A FIREFIGHTER
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER OR
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE RETIRES THEY
WILL HAVE A FIXED MONTHLY.
PENSION TO MEET THEIR DAY TO
DAY. MOREOVER UNLIKE PRESENTS A
EMPLOYEE MANY. AND INCLUDING
OUTSIDE PERSON OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
DO NOT. SO SECURITY BENEFITS.
FOR THESE RETIRED SIX. IS
TYPICALLY ONLY OF RETIREMENT
INCOME. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
PROTECT THAT RETIREE BY
ENSURING THE BENEFIT THAT WAS
BARGAINING PAID FOR IS
MAINTAINED. AND THE SITUATION
FOR THE DAVIS FIREFIGHTER DOES
NOT HAPPEN FOR FUTURE RETIREES.
EXISTING ALONG CALPERS
REGULATION HAS. ESTABLISHED
RULES AROUND CATEGORIES OF
COMPENSATION SUCH AS LONGEVITY
K. HAS OKAY AND EDUCATIONAL
CENTER K. SOME EXAMPLES OF
THESE ROLLS AROUND THIS
COMPENSATION MOST. IS THAT THE
COMPENSATION MUST BE AVAILABLE
TO THE ENTIRE GROUP OF CLASSES
ELIGIBLE FOR THE ADAM. AND THE
COMPETITION I DON'T- IS
AVAILABLE ON A- JEWEL PLEASE
BAR ADAMS ARE TO BE. AND
REPORTED TO THE SYSTEM OKAY IF
THEY ARE NOT WE COULD FIND A
SITUATION WHERE PAN AM IS
DISALLOWED BY THE SYSTEM.
GENERATIONS OF HARD WORKING
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA'S MIDDLE
CLASS HAVE DEDICATED THEIR
CAREERS TO PUBLIC SERVICE OFTEN
EARNING LESS OVER THE COURSE OF
THEIR CAREER WHEN COMPARED TO
THEIR PRIVATE INDUSTRY
COUNTERPARTS TO EARN AND PAY
FOR THE PROMISE OF A SECURE
RETIREMENT. WE BELIEVE SB TWO
SEVEN EIGHT IS IT IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO PROTECT THE PROMISE
OF A SECURE RETIREMENT FOR
THESE REASONS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SUBER'S. WE WILL MOVE
ON NO ONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
B. TWO SEVENTY. PLEASE COME
FORWARD SEEN NONE. ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO WISHES TO
FIND SUPPORT THE BEST B. TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT. HAVE SEEN NONE
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR PETE PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WILLING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT. WE MAY BEGIN. PLEASE
HOLD A MINUTE A MINUTE YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE AT THIS TIME. PLEASE MAKE
CERTAIN THAT YOUR PHONE ISN'T
IT IS ON MUTED BEFORE YOU PRESS
ANY BUTTONS THEN PLEASE MAKE
CERTAIN THAT THAT VICE EUROPE'S
USING FOR THE ZOOM MEETING IS
MINUTE. WE WILL MOVE TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT OUR FIRST COMMENT.
PLEASE PROCEED LINE TWENTY
EIGHT WHAT. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WE'RE HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. WILL MOVE TO LINE
TWENTY NINE FOR THE FIRST
COMMENT ONE MOMENT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS PAT MORAN WITH
THE KERN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
CITING. PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE THIRTY
NINE GO AHEAD. THE TEACHER
MEMBERS RANDY PERRY WITH THEIR
READING IT SAYS IT'S ON BEHALF
OF YOUR ACT WARNS TOLD
SUPPORTERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THEY WILL GO BACK TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE.
TIGER WOODS THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SAMATAR
DESERVE CONCLUDE TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVENTY.
WE HAVE MISTER EDWARDS- ARE
QUEUING UP I WILL OPEN UP HIS
LINE AS WELL. JUST READ WHAT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CAL FIRE LOCAL TWENTY
ONE PRESIDENT CHEN EDWARDS
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR OF WILL. NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHICH IS TOUGH FOR IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL. C.
NONE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
AS FAR IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT. C. NONE BUT
WE WILL COME BACK TO THE
MODERATOR AND- ASK HIM TO PROP
THE INDIVIDUALS NGUYEN TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT BY TELECONFERENCE
A PLEASE BE ON. THANK YOU AND
IF THERE ARE ANY. ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCHTONE PHONE AT
THIS TIME. THIS YEAR AS JOHN IT
WAS WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION ON THE
LINE CAN YOU HEAR ME. COULD YOU
PLEASE SPEAK MORE LOUDLY AND
REPEAT YOUR- YOUR NAME AND
TITLE. YES YES. HI MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DILLON
GIBBONS WITH THE ALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO U. S. B. TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT- THANKS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO CALL AND- FIRST
I'D LIKE TO START BY SAYING
THAT IT'S TRULY UNFORTUNATE
WHEN RETIREES HAVE THEIR
PENSIONS CUT. YOUR NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. AND WE SHOULD WORK
TOGETHER TO FIND A REMEDY AS
WELL AS IDENTIFY STEPS SHOULD
BE TAKEN TO PREVENT IT FROM
EVER HAPPENING IN THE FIRST
PLACE. UNFORTUNATELY SB TWO
SEVEN EIGHT IS NOT THE
APPROPRIATE READY FOR MAKING
RETIREES WHOSE PENSIONS ARE CUT
HOLE. WHEN CALPERS TAKES STEPS
TO DISALLOW CERTAIN PENSION
BENEFITS BECAUSE THOSE BENEFITS
VIOLATE PENSION LAW. CALPERS IS
UNABLE TO PAY OUT A PENSION TO
VIOLATE THE LAW IN THE SAME WAY
THE PUBLIC AGENCIES WILL BE
UNABLE TO PAY FOR PENSION
BENEFITS THE PILOT THE LAW.
CONTINUED PAYMENT OF AN
UNLAWFUL BENEFIT TO RETIREES
WOULD COST YOU TO GET THE
PUBLIC FUNDS. THE VIOLATION OF
SECTION SIX OF ARTICLE SIXTEEN
OF THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
SUCH VIOLATIONS REPUBLICAN REP
TO DEFEND ITSELF AND POP
EDUCATION LAWSUITS. FILED BY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. ALLEN
PUT AGENCY TO PAY. PENSIONS BY
EXTENSION FROM AND CERTAIN THE
EMPLOYEES PENSION REFORM ACT.
BETTER KNOWN AS PAPA. THIS IS
WHAT GOVERNOR BROWN B. TO A
SIMILAR BILL TWENTY. TO BE- MET.
ABOUT THE IN PART. OF THIS BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH RETIREE BERMAN
RIGHT TO INCORRECTLY. PENSION
BENEFITS AND CAN WHERE AN ERROR
RESULT. IN THE RETIREE THAN
BENEFITS THAT BY LAW. I SURE
THE OPTIONS YOU THAT ATTENTION
MUST BE CORRECTLY CALCULATED
ACCORDING TO THE LAW IN THE
FIRST INSTANCE. SO THAT
RETIREES NEVER FIND THEMSELVES
ON THE HOOK FOR OVERPAYMENT.
PLEASE ENTER USER NEEDED TO
CORRECT THAT SITUATION. BUT I'M
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILLS BROAD
PROVISIONS COULD BE EASILY USED
TO CIRCUMVENT LIMITATIONS IN
LAW INTENDED TO PROTECT THE
GOVERNMENT. AND ULTIMATELY
TAXPAYERS. THE PENSIONS BY
INDEED AND A- OF A ERROR THIS
BILL WOULD AFFECT. EFFECTUATE
THAT ERROR FOR THE REST THE
MEMBERS. THE SIXTY TAX THE
ATTACK EXPENSE IN. AGAIN IT IS
UNFORTUNATE THAT AFTERNOON
AGENCY AND THE PRO AND IT CAME
TO AGREEMENT ON BENEFITS AND
THOSE BENEFITS BE PAID FOR ANY
OUT OF POCKET. AFTER THAT BUT
IF TO BE FROM THE RETIRED. IF
YOU JUST MAKE IT MORE ME OR
AFTER CONTEMPT TO DO. PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND CONTINUE TO MAKE.
PAYMENTS DIRECTLY TO WEEK FROM
ON OCTOBER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS I YOUR
MOBILE SB TWO SEVENTY. THANK
YOU MISTER SERVED IN MY POLL
SIR FOR ME ON TO THE RUBIO
CALLING UPON YOU YOU WERE OF. A
SHOULD HAVE GONE EARLIER ON THE
AGENDA- I UNDERSTAND THERE IS-
ANOTHER OPPOSITION WITNESS
ONLINE IS THAT CORRECT. YES MR
HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS IS
THE ST MARY R. WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES WE CAN
HEAR YOU FINE- PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON. THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IS OPPOSED SB
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT WE SHARE
LARGELY THE CONCERN BUT MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION SHARED.
PRIMARILY THAT WE ENGAGE AND
BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH. TO
ESTABLISH THESE BENEFITS WERE
COMMITTED TO PAYING THEM AT THE
POINT WHEN THEY WERE
NEGOTIATED. BUT UNFORTUNATELY
IN THE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
CALPERS. OFTENTIMES AFTER
SEVERAL AUDITS DETERMINES. THAT
THE BENEFITS ARE DISALLOWED.
FOR US YOU HAVE BIG SHOULDER
THAT COST AND MAKE UP FOR
DETERMINATION THAT'S MADE BY
CALPERS WE THINK ON ON OUR END.
IT IS PROPS FUNDAMENTALLY
UNFAIR BUT ALSO DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING TO RESOLVE THE ISSUE.
OF MAKING SURE THAT OUR
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS ARE
PROPERLY OVERSEEN. WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE RESPONSIBILITY
BE TAKEN ON BY THE PENSION
SYSTEM IN BEING INVOLVED. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL BROAD
REVISIONS PRESENT NOT JUST A
LARGE FISCAL COMMITMENT TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. BUT AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED DO
CERTAINLY CREATE A MORAL HAZARD
THAT COULD ALLOW CIRCUMVENTING
UP HAVE BROKE WHICH DEEPLY
CONCERNS US FROM A GOOD
GOVERNANCE PERSPECTIVE. THAT
COUPLED WITH THE UNRESOLVED
QUESTION OF HOW BENEFITS BUT
CALPERS DETERMINES OUR LEGAL TO
PAY CAN SOMEHOW BEING EIGHT
LEGAL IF WE AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WORK AND MAKE THEM.
STILL REMAINS UNRESOLVED AND WE
DO THINK PRESENTS A SERIOUS
QUESTION. AS TO WHETHER THIS
MEASURE OF THE APPROPRIATE
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM. BUT
THE ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE OF RIGHTLY IDENTIFIED
AS IT WISHES THAT. RETIREES CAN
BE LEFT ON THE HOOK FOR WHEN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES. OF CAR WE'RE
WE'RE DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
TRYING TO RESOLVE THE SITUATION
AND NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH BUT
THE ADVOCATES ON THE OTHER
SIDE. TO TRY AND RESOLVE THE
ISSUE BUT THIS MEASURE AS IT
CURRENTLY IS PRESENT DEEP.
FISCAL AND GOVERNANCE
CHALLENGES. TO US INTO OUR
MEMBERSHIP AND WE BECAUSE OF
THE BAD WE RESPECTFULLY AND
HUMBLY HAVE TO OPPOSE THE
LEGISLATION AND REQUEST YOUR
KNOW. ABOUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. OKAY THANK YOU BELIEVE
THAT THE- SO TESTAMENT IT WOULD
RECEIVE ON LAW- BECAUSE I TOOK
THE- IS A SITE YOU ARE. OLD
CALL ONE MORE TIME FOR ME WITH
THIS IN THE- IN ROOM TWENTY
FOUR. UNINDICTED THE MODERATOR-
ONE MORE TIME DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO S. B.
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT- QUEUED UP TO
TESTIFY THROUGH THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. IF THERE
ARE ANY OF SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY
SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHECHNYA
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. ALSO
REGRETFULLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THERE ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR- WE WILL COME BACK.
TO THE COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME
AND LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FIRST
BROWSER I JUST MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY WILL COME BACK TO FOR THE
MOTION- SOON AS A MATTER BY
SURE CUT COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
PLEASE PLEASE. I'M GLAD YOU
BROUGHT THIS BILL FORWARD
BECAUSE I CAN'T IMAGINE BEING A
RETIREE AND RECEIVING A BALE OF.
IN A FORTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN BACK PAY- THAT HAD TO BE
RETURNED I THINK OF IT OF NEW
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE REASSESSING
THEIR PROPERTIES AND GET THAT
HE SAYS YOU KNOW- PROPERTY TAX
BILL AND THEY KIND OF LOOK AT
YOU THAT'S WHAT IS THIS DO SO.
A LOT OF INFORMATION BEING
DISCLOSED RIGHT NOW WITH NEW
HOMEOWNERS LETTING THEM KNOW
YOU WILL BE RECESSED AND YOU
WILL BE GETTING A SUPPLEMENTAL
TAX BILL- BUT I AM A LITTLE
CONCERNED BECAUSE- AS I LOOK AT
THIS BILL- I KEEP ASKING MYSELF
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS DOES
THIS BILL FIX. THE ISSUE. AND
MY QUESTION IS- BECAUSE WE HAD
TO ENTITIES THAT ARE IT THAT
ARE BURKE THAT REPRESENT THE
BEST. OR THE INTEREST OF THE
RETIREE. OR THE EMPLOYEE I
WANTED TO GO SHE ADDED. AS A
FRESHMAN CENTER HELP ME
UNDERSTAND HOW IS IT THAT THEY
CAN NEGOTIATE FOR THE
BARGAINING UNIT AND THE AGENCY.
CAN NEGOTIATE A CONTRACT AND
THEN HAVE CALPERS SAY THESE
ITEMS ARE DISALLOWED THESE ARE
NOT INCLUDED IN THERE. AND IS
THERE A LIST OF THINGS THAT ARE
NOT ALLOWED. I'M I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO YOU MAKE THIS
BILL- I GUESS WORTHY OF
PROTECTING THE RETIREES FROM
EVER HAPPENING AGAIN AND WHAT
WOULD HAVE TO BE INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL IN ORDER TO PROTECT
RETIREES FROM BARGAINING
SCENARIOS WHERE IT MAKES SENSE
EXPECT SUSCEPTIBLE TO THIS
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING IN THAT NATURE THEN
THE TAXPAYERS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PICKING UP THE BILL FOR
THESE FOR THESE TYPE OF.
CONTRACTS OR- THESE THIS
ALLOWABLE IS- BECAUSE SOMEBODY
HAS TO PAY AND IT'S WHETHER
IT'S THE RETIRED OR NOT IT'S
ULTIMATELY THE TAXPAYER. RICK
THANK YOU SENATOR I'M GONNA
TAKE A STAB AT IT AND THEN I
THINK DOUG IS STILL ON THE LINE
THEY'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
JUMP IN IF I DON'T GET IT QUITE
RIGHT. WHEN GOVERNOR BROWN
VETOED THIS BILL BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ONE OF THE%
THINGS HE ASKED WAS THAT THERE
SHOULD BE POLICIES IN PLACE TO
REQUIRE THAT CALPERS REVIEW AND
APPROVE ANY PROPOSAL FOR
POTENTIAL COMPENSATION IN AN MO
YOU BEFORE IT IS FINALIZED. TO
HELP MAKE SURE THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN WITH THIS ALLOWABLE
COMPENSATION TO SEVENTY EIGHT
DOES THAT SO WE THINK THAT THIS
BILL FIXES THAT PROBLEM AND I'M
JUST HOUSING DOUG TO JUMP IN IF
HE THINKS THE THERE'S MORE TO
IT THAT SHOULD BE ADDED. MISTER
SUPERSU ABOARD AT. THANKS
MISTER CHAIRMAN CENTER LEYVA I
THINK I'M I WOULD I WOULD JUST
ADD THAT- THE THERE ARE THERE
IS A LIST OF PHONES COMPENSABLE
ITEMS AND REGULATIONS AROUND
THOSE ITEMS THAT THAT CALPERS
MAINTAINS BUT- IN ADDITION TO
THE THAT LISTA BEING PROVIDED-
THOSE PAY ITEMS ALSO HAVE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN A FASHION
THROUGHOUT THE TERM OF. YOUR
CONTRACT- THAT IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE RULES JUST SO FOR
EXAMPLE- AND INCENTIVE PAY ITEM
MAYBE FOR EDUCATIONAL INCENTIVE
PAID THE OUR UNDERSTANDING IT
NEEDS TO BE OFFERED TO THE
ENTIRE CLASS SO FOR EXAMPLE
ANYBODY THAT- IN- A SUBSET OF
THE EMPLOYER. PLEASE ACHIEVED
THIS IT. PAY EITHER MORE OUT OF
CERTIFICATE AND BACHELOR'S
DEGREE FROM- EVERYBODY IN THE
CLASS WE NEED TO BE OFFERED
THAT- THAT BENEFIT. IF FOR SOME
REASON THE EMPLOYER THERE WAS
IMPLEMENTED A MATTER WHAT THE
EMPLOYER ONLY PROVIDED THAT
BENEFITS US UPSET- DOES INTO.
AT THAT HAD MET EDGE- INCENTIVE
REQUIREMENTS IT THAT COULD BE
SUBJECT OR- THE PAY ITEM BEING
DISALLOWED BECAUSE IT WAS
OFFERED TO THE- ENTIRE CLASS
SO. IN ADDITION YOU KNOW THE
PROMISE OF THE BILLS THAT THIS
WAS A BARGAIN AND- CONTINUED
FOR BENEFIT THAT AT THE TIME
EVERYBODY BELIEVED- WAS
APPROPRIATE. HOWEVER PERHAPS IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OR OTHER
OTHER SITUATION- IT WASN'T
IMPLEMENTED FASHION WHICH
RESULTS IN THE DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION AND RIGHT NOW THE
EMPLOYEE- IS LEFT WITH THE
ENTIRE OBLIGATION AND- LESSER
RECOURSE AFTER THEY'VE. ALREADY
RETIRED BUT THE. SO IT THERE
TIME FOR ME WHICH- THESE
CONTRACTS HAVE TO BE. VETTED
AND CONFIRMED AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT THEY NEED- THE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS OF WHAT IS ALLOWED.
EACH THE BA IS DIFFERENT AND
WHEN IT IS COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED AT THAT WOULD HAVE
TIME FRAME SENATE DEPENDING ON
WHAT CLASSIFICATION WAS BEING
BARGAINED ARE YOU IS THAT WHAT
YOUR QUESTION SENATOR OR YOUR
QUESTION. WHEN CAN THE IS THERE
A TIME FRAME IN WHICH THEY CAN
GO AFTER THESE MONIES. LIKE A
SUNSET. SO I THINK WHAT I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND ASKED TO.
WHEN THESE THESE. THESE
NEGOTIATIONS ARE COMPLETED
THEIR SUBMITTED TO CALPERS HOW
LONG SHOULD WE HAVE THIS OPEN.
S. T. BEING LEGITIMATE SO THAT
IN THE FUTURE WE DON'T HAVE
THEM COMING BACK AND SAYING
THREE FOUR FIVE YEARS LATER
SAYING OKAY WE ONLY OWE THIS
AMOUNT OF MONEY BECAUSE WE
OVERPAID YOU I'M TRYING TO JUST
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHEN CAN WE
CAN WE IS IT REASONABLE TO ASK
FOR EIGHTY. TIME PERIOD IN
WHICH THESE CONTRACTS SHOULD BE
VERIFIED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
MEET- LEGAL REQUIREMENTS PER
SE- SO THAT. THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN. BUT WHAT YOU'RE IN THIS
BILL DOES NOT DO WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING SAY OKAY DID IT YOU THAT
YOU WIN THEY THEY GET TOGETHER
AND THE NEGOTIATE WITH THE
BENEFIT SHOULD BE ALLOWED
COMPENSATION DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION IT HAS TO BE
AGREED UPON OF WITHIN X. AMOUNT
OF DAYS MONTHS WEEKS THIS BILL
DOES NOT DO THAT DO YOU WANT TO
ADD ANYTHING TO THAT. THERE'S A
TIME FRAME IN THE BILL YES I.
YEAH THAT'S NOT GOOD THAT'S AND
IF I MADE THE- I THINK IF YOU
LOOK AT SUBDIVISION SEEING- IN
THE MEASURE IF I. EMPLOYER A
LACK TO HAVE A. I HAVE-
PROPOSAL REVIEW- BY. STATE CAN
DO SO. UNDER THE BILL. AND HAVE-
VIEW THE ITEM AND TAKE A LOOK
AT THE THAT- YOU KNOW THE
PATTERN THAT ARE IN THE- MEMO
YOU. AMONG YOUR IN. MAY I- THE
MEMBERSHIP I AM I'M IN THE
QUESTION OF TOO IN THEN PARDON
ME IF I'M WRONG I'LL CAN-
CORRECT ME- WHICH IS THAT THIS
POINT IN THE IS THERE- ANY KIND
OF BURDEN CAL. TO A STEP HIS
DROP THE DAY SO THIS FOR- FOUR
WHEN THE COOLS. THANK YOU FOR.
CENTER URBAN READY TO COMMENT
WHENEVER OKAY YOU'RE DONE. SO
MY CONCERN IS THAT ALTHOUGH
THIS BILL PROTECTS THE RETIREE.
THE ISSUE AT HAND IS NOT FIXED
BY THIS BILL IS THAT CORRECT WE
DO BELIEVE IT IS FIXED BY THIS
BILL YES. DATE ONLY THE ISSUE
OF THE RETIREE BILL PROTECTED
CORRECT. AT THE END PART OF
WHAT I THINK I TRIED TO ANSWER
THAT WHEN YOU ASKED IT IN THE
FIRST PLACE THAT WE TRIED TO
ADDRESS THAT IN THE VETO
MESSAGE FROM GOVERNOR BROWNBACK
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND WE
DO BELIEVE THAT CALPERS IS HAS
MORE RESPONSIBILITY NOW AND
THAT IT DOES GO A LONG WAY OF
FIXING THAT PROBLEM. OKAY OKAY.
WITH YOUR. I'M JUST ONE
COMMENT- OR QUESTION M. WHAT
HAVE WITH- NON REPRESENT AT
EMPLOYEES SO NON UNION
EMPLOYEES CAN THIS HAPPEN TO
THEM AND WILL THEY BE PROTECTED
UNDER THIS BILL OF COURSE IT
CAN HAPPEN TO NON REPRESENT
EMPLOYEES AND THAT'S A GREAT
POINT FOR WHY YOU SHOULD BE
UNION MEMBER BECAUSE THEN YOU
HAVE PROTECTIONS BUT IF YOU'RE
NON UNION MEMBER YOU DO NOT
HAVE A COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED
AGREEMENT SO THIS WOULD NOT
APPLY TO YOU. SO THEY DON'T
HAVE IT YOU WOULD HAVE SOME
SORT OF AN AGREEMENT WITH YOUR
EMPLOYER THERE WAS NOT
COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED AND IS
NOT ENFORCEABLE. OKAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME OKAY
THANK YOU AND UP TO SENATOR- I
CAN'T HELP MY BUT TRYING CALM
IT HERE IS THE AND OF PUT SOME
POINTS ON THIS THIS BILL IS
ABOUT AN INJUSTICE. AND
INJUSTICE IS SOMEBODY MAKES A
DECISION BASED ON WHAT CALPERS
TELLS THEM ABOUT WHETHER THEY
HAVE THE FINANCIAL WHERE WITH
ALL TO RETIRE AND THEY CAN LIVE
OFF OF THEIR RETIREMENT. A AND
A NUMBER OF YEARS IN- THIS IT'S
MUCH LOWER AND IT'S NOT JUST OF
THE FORTUNE SITUATION WHERE
THEY HAVE TO LIVE OFF OF MUCH
LESS THAN I THOUGHT THEY WERE
WHEN THEY RETIRED. THEY BACK
THE DIFFERENCE SETTING A TIME
DEADLINE JUST MEANS THAT IF
WITH THE DAVIS FIREFIGHTER
THERE WAS AN INJUSTICE AT FIVE
YEARS HE JUST MOVED IN JUSTICE
TO TWO YEARS OR ONE YEAR BUT AT
LEAST THE INJUSTICE. AND SO THE
QUESTION IS WHAT TO DO HERE AND
I THINK THAT. WHAT THIS BILL
DOES THIS BY PUTTING THE ONUS
ON THE EMPLOYER WHO IS THE. ONE
THAT DOES THE REPORTING. THE HI
TO IT'S GOING TO BE A MOTOR-
FOR CORRECT REPORT. THEY HAD A
RIGHT ED AND DEEP DOWN QUE.
SHOULD BE THE ONE THAT THAT
TAKES A BIT SHARE OF. BUT A IS
HOW IT IS THREE. THAT THEN HOW
ARE CALPERS. THE TERM IT WE- TO
THE PROBLEM. ANY. BUT I SPENT
TWENTY FIVE AS A LAW GUY
EMPLOYEE IN THE COW SYSTEM. A
AND THINK I WAS. BY YOU FOR
FORTY OF THE TIME IN A MEMBER
OF THE U. AND I GOT. APPOINTED
PICK ME SOME RELEASE THAT DOES
NOT INCLUDE MAN BECAUSE WERE ON.
WE WERE AT THEIR MERCY AND IF
THEY MAKE IN THEIR THAT SHOULD
BE A TO EXACTLY THE SAME WAY
AND THEY SHOULD BE LIABLE AN
EXACT THE SAME WAY- EVEN THOUGH
THIS BILL THE- DO IT SO I THINK
THE BILL WAS THE RIGHT. NOW
BECAUSE IN ADDITION TO A THE
IT'S TO MOTIVATE. I THINK OVER
TIME WARM. THIS BE DONE RIGHT
BECAUSE IT'S THERE. THAN IN THE
WORLD. IF THIS IS A MOTIVE.
AFTER A WHILE BILL NEED TO BE
USE. BECAUSE IT BE RE CARILLO.
CAL POLY PERSONAL BE WORKING
WITH THEM AS WELL. ALTHOUGH
THERE'S GOT TO BE AWARE POINT
CALPERS HAS A LITTLE RESPONSE.
HERE BUT THOSE GUY. ARE ONES
ARE PROVIDE THE IN. THAT FIVE
YEAR LATER RESULT TO. THAT THAT
IS A MAJOR PAY BACK AND LOWER
AND BASED ON A DECISION
SOMEBODY MADE TO RETIRE SO. I
THINK THIS IS THE BEST OF A
NUMBER OF ALTERNATIVES AND MY
HOPE WOULD BE. THAT OVER TIME
THIS WOULD NEED TO BE USED
BECAUSE OF THE FORCING THE
RIGHT DECISION TO BE MADE AND
HOW IT'S REPORTED AND HOW IT'S
DONE SO. WHENEVER WE GET TO A
POINT THAT WE ALLOW MOTION CALL
VOTE ON. THE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED
THE I JUST WANT TO I'M SO TO
THE ISSUE OF CALL HAVING SOME
AND RISK TO MAYBE THAT GOES
BEYOND THIS BILL BUT I'M ALSO
INTO TO SOME THE BILL IT IT THE-
MOVES THE BALL QUITE. FOR DOWN
THE FIELD IN TERMS OF. THE
RIGHT THING TO DO SO THAT'S- IN
CENTER NEW INYO I'M VERY VERY
QUICKLY BECAUSE- A SIMILAR
INSPIRE- SO THIS IS A GOOD BILL
THIS DOES. NOT FINE DID GO TO
BE IN ONCE IN A- THE IT THIS
YEAR BECAUSE IT DOES RAY KLAY.
UPON THE ALL SHOULD AND IN
WHICH NOT- PENALIZED THE-
PARTICULAR THE RETURN FOR
HAVING- THE CHOIR DENNIS INTO
THAT WERE BARKING IN GOOD. YEAH
AND TO YOUR POINT SINCE EARLIER
THAT SIX WHAT WE'RE HERE AND I
THINK OVER TIME- IF THE LOCAL
ENTITY THE CALPERS HAVE THE OUT
THEY WILL THINK. LONG AND HARD
ABOUT TO TELL FIX FOR AND WE
WILL THAT SO YOU FOR THIS BILL
SENATE LEYVA. THANK YOU SIR
ROOF THERE'S NOTHING- SO LABOR
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE WITH A.
THERE'S A STRENGTH IN THE
NUMBERS. WE POINTED OUT ONE
MISTER SUPERSPORT OUT ONE-
ISSUE THEY'VE BEEN SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE PEOPLE WHO HAS
BEEN AFFECTED BY A SOMEONE WHO
SAT ON A PENSION FUND FOR
TWELVE YEARS PEOPLE PLAN THEIR
LIFE THEY MAKE LIFE DECISIONS
BASED ON WHAT THEY ARE TOLD.
AND IS NOT THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN THAT THEIR PENSION IS
REDUCED IT IS A LIFE CHANGING
IN A VERY NEGATIVE WAY TO HAVE
TO PAY BACK MONIES AND HAVE
YOUR PENSION REDUCED SO THIS
BILL WILL PUT MORE ONUS ON
CALPERS AND LESS ONUS ON THE
WORKER LESS ONUS ON THE PERSON
WHO IS RELYING ON THIS AND
WORKS TWENTY THIRTY FORTY
YEARS. AND KNOW THAT THEY CAN
RETIRE AND NOT LIVE IN POVERTY
THEY HOPE THIS BILL WILL MAKE
SURE THAT THAT HOPE IS A
REALITY ADDITIONALLY I JUST
WANTED TO- ADDRESS SOMETHING
THAT THE GERMAN FROM THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
SAID. HE SAID THAT THIS IS A
GIFT OF PUBLIC FUNDS IN THIS IS
THE THIRD TIME WE'RE WORKING ON
THIS BILL AND I WOULD JUST
REALLY LIKE IT IF OPPOSITION
WOULD STOP CALLING IT A GIFT OF
PUBLIC FUNDS BECAUSE IT IS NOT
A GIFT OF PUBLIC FUNDS IT'S
JUST NOT FACTUAL THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS LAWFULLY
EXECUTED. THROUGH A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT SO IT IS
NOT A GIFT OF PUBLIC FUNDS BUT
THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU CENTER AND
A NEW CENTER DRAWS US WE
RECOGNIZE OUR- FOR MOTION.
BASED ON EVERYBODY'S COMMENTS I
AM PROUD TO MOVE S. B. TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU CENTER
THANK YOU MOTION BY TWO ROWS OF
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO SENATE
JUDICIARY YES FOR MR. BONTA
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. SENATE
QUARTERS THE BY. PROPOSING
FIVE. SENATOR PER CHIU ABOVE.
BY IN ORDER TO BOOK BY CENTER
DORADO I THE ADDRESS THE HI
CENTER LAYER HI CAN EARLIER. HI
CENTER NEW HI CENTER NEWMAN THE
BILL'S FIVE VOTES. THE BILL SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THE CENTER LEYVA YOU- FEE
PROCEED WITH SB TWO FOUR AND-
ME JUST SAY I KNOW CENTERS IS
AWAY AND WILL BE TAKE YOUR BILL
UP IN OUR BETWEEN CENTERS
CENTER LABOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THIS BILL HAS AN
OPPOSITE SO IT SHOULD BE NICE
AND QUICK. SB TWO NINETY FOUR
RIVER REMOVES A TWELVE YEAR
MAXIMUM SERVICE CREDIT CAP THAT
CAN BE EARNED BY AN EDUCATOR
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES AND
EDUCATORS CAN TAKE A LEAVE FROM
THEIR JOB TO ACT AS A STEWARD
OR REPRESENTATIVES OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE STATE OR NATIONAL
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION. THESE
UNION REPRESENTATIVES MAY SPEND
SEVERAL YEARS AWAY FROM THE
OFFICE OR CLASSROOM ADVOCATING
FOR IMPROVED WORKING CONDITIONS
AND EMPLOYEE RIGHTS WELL AS
SERVICE CLASS. GIVE ME A
SERVICE CAP DOES NOT APPLY TO
EVERY PUBLIC EMPLOYEE INCLUDING
PEACE OFFICERS FIREFIGHTERS
CITY AND COUNTY EMPLOYEES IT
DOES APPLY TO EDUCATORS SB TWO
NINETY FOUR SIMPLY REMOVE SET
TWELVE YEAR CAP TO ENSURE THAT
EDUCATORS HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEES THE BILL HAS NO
POSITION. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. WHO DO YOU
THINK AND SPEAKING IN SUPPORT I
HAVE SEPTEMBER FROM C. AND
TRISTON BROWN SEE IF. TRISTIAN
BROWN OKAY- WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED- ONLINE HIGH ASSUME-
SOUTH BRAMBLE FIRST. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CARE AND SENATORS-
I DON'T A SPECTRUM BUT WE ON
BEHALF OF MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
MEDICATIONS IN THE STATE THE
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PROUD. TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HER LEADERSHIP. IT IS A
MISSION TO THE CONDITIONS
TEACHING AND LEARNING WHEN WE
RECOGNIZE THAT GIVING TEACHERS
GREATER VOICE. PRODUCES
FRUSTRATION AND TURNOVER-
SENATOR LEYVA MENTIONED TWELVE
EDUCATORS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES ARE THE ONLY PUBLIC
COMPLAIN ABOUT OUT. OF TWELVE
YEARS ON THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
SERVICE CREDIT. THE CONCERN FOR
THE PENSIONS WILL ALLOW ME TO
SERVE THEIR ONE. THIS ONE ARE
UNFAIRLY SINGLED OUT EDUCATION
EMPLOYEES CAN HARM THEIR
ABILITY. TO TAKE A LEAVE OF
ABSENCE TO REPRESENT THE UNION
WITHOUT LOSING BENEFITS. DURING
THE TIME OF SERVICE. LEAVE ON A
SCHOOL AND WITH BY THE COURT.
WILL BE CLOSED. THE CALIFORNIA
GIVE US. SENT JUNE THREE ON TO.
WAS STILL JUST OF DEDICATED ON
THE CAR BURDEN CLOUT JUSTICE
AND RESOURCE. FOR ALL OF.
STUDENTS TEACHERS. AND
CLASSROOMS SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY FOUR THE SPRING. SIMPLE
BILL AND THE OTHER DRIVER.
THANK YOU. WE WILL MOVE ON TO
AND WHO. ONLINE TO FINDS. I'M
SORRY IF I MISPRONOUNCED YOUR
NAME IS SIR ANOTHER WITNESS
ONLINE. SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
OKAY. HARETA APPARENTLY NOT
PRESIDENT- LET ME JUST TO MOVE
ON THEN ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD. C.
NONE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WAS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO NINETY
FOUR. C. NINE WILL MOVE ON TO A
MODERATOR IN ASKING IF THERE
ARE WITNESSES WINDOWS HAS BY
HIMSELF IN SUPPORT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR BUSINESS
MODERN. THANK YOU AND IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
NINETY FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE PICK UP YOUR HANDSET
BEFORE YOU PRESS ANY BUTTONS
ALSO ADD THAT YOU'VE MUTU
RESUME EATING BEFORE YOU SPEAK.
WELL FIRST TO LINE FORTY NINE
GO AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS OF THE
FAMILY. OF THE TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA. ASIAN STOCK MARKETS.
THANK YOU. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
NINETEEN GO AHEAD. THE SANTAS
ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE.
BY TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TOMORROW CAN WE MOVE ON.
YES SO THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES
INTO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ONE MORE
TIME PLEASE. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO NINETY
FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE ARE
GOING TO ADD UP. GREAT THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW ALLOW TIME FOR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS- THERE ARE NO
OPPOSITION FOR WITNESSES ONLINE
IS THAT CORRECT. SEEING NONE.
OF THE LAST CONSIDER ANY
WITNESSES WHICH SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IF SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
SEE NONE OTHER THAN ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SEEN NONE- WILL OVE
ON TO THE MODERATOR IN BACK TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE- MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINE TO ANY WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SB TWO NINETY FOUR AND CALL
THEM INDIVIDUALLY PLEASE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WERE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO NINETY
FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WERE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY NOW TO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN INTO AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR
OF BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR FURTHER
DISCUSSION YES OF MEMBERSHIP.
I'VE BEEN VERY TALKATIVE THIS
COMMITTEE IT IS OKAY. I DO HAVE
A LOT OF QUESTIONS BEING THAT
IT IS MY FIRST- COMMITTEE WERE
ACTUALLY DISCUSSING THE BILL'S
IN DETAIL IN VOTING ON THEM BUT
I DO HAVE A QUESTION. SO RIGHT
NOW WITH THE TWELVE YEAR CAP.
IT INCENTIVIZES TEACHERS TO
KIND OF ROTATED I SEE IT SORT
OF. AS TERM LIMITS FOR
LEGISLATORS. BECAUSE YOU ARE
YOU FRANCE'S YOU RUN FOR TWELVE
YEARS MAXIMUM IF YOU'RE IN THE
SENATE RIGHT NOW AND THEN YOU
HAVE NEW VOICES COMING IN YOUR
LIFE EXPERIENCES. WITH THE CAP
RIGHT NOW IS THAT EXIST IT
ACTUALLY INCENTIVIZES. ROTATION
OF LEADERSHIP IN THE UNIONS AND
IT ALLOWS FOR NEAR VOICES
RECENT VOICES HAVE BEEN IN THE
CLASSROOM TO COME IN AND
REPRESENT THEIR THEIR
MEMBERSHIP. SOME A LITTLE
CONCERNED DO YOU SEE THAT BEING
GAY AND ALSO BECAUSE I SEE IT
AS- AN INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE TO
STAY. IN LEADERSHIP FOR LONGER
SORT OF LIKE CONGRESS VERSUS
THE STATE LEGISLATURE. IN A WAY
AND IT IT JUST SENT TO VICE'S
NEW LEADERSHIP NEW VOICES
COMING IN AND LEADING THE
BARGAINING UNITS WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT SENATOR GREAT
QUESTION. SO THEY'RE TWO
DIFFERENT BECAUSE UNIONS PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SECTORS I'M SURE
YOU'RE AWARE THIS WILL ONLY
AFFECT A PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEES PART OF IT IS
FAIRNESS BECAUSE THESE ARE THE
ONLY- PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE GIVEN A CAP. AS I
STATED IN MY OPENING ALL THE
OTHER UNIONS AND PUBLIC SECTOR
DON'T HAVE A CAP SO THEY CAN
PULL SOMEONE OUT FOR AS LONG AS
THEY WISH. AND EVERY EVERY-
BARGAINING UNIT IS DIFFERENT
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT PUBLIC
SECTOR VERSUS PRIVATE SECTOR
PRIVATE SECTOR WE DO A SHORTER
AMOUNT OF TIME AND WE PULLED
THE ROTATION IS THERE. AND
PUBLIC SECTOR PEOPLE TEND TO
STAY A LITTLE LONGER AND IT'S A
WAY TO KEEP PEOPLE IN AN ALMOST
HALF HOUR IF NOT ALMOST BUT
HAVE A CAREER. IN THE LABOR
MOVEMENT REPRESENTING WORKERS
AND IS SOMEONE WHO WORK IN THE
LABOR MOVEMENT FOR THIRTY YEARS
AND REPRESENT WORKERS FOR
TWENTY OF THOSE YEARS. THE MORE
TIME YOU HAVE BEEN THE BETTER
THOSE CONTRACTS CAN BE VERY
COMPLEX AND VERY HARD TO
UNDERSTAND SO I SEE HAVING MORE
THAN TWELVE YEARS AS A BENEFIT.
ROTATING LEADERSHIP YEAH IT
COULD BE GOOD SOMETIMES YOU
BRING SOMEONE IN BRAND NEW WHO
HAS NO IDEA- MAYBE. WHAT THE
CONTRACT IS THIS IS A WAY TO
CREATE SOME KIND. AND AS IT LOW
I SAID. IN THESE EDUCATORS ARE
THE ONLY ONES FOR LEFT OUT OF
THIS. OKAY THANK YOU OTHER
COMES TO QUESTIONS. THE C.
NONE. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. DONT SEE NONE SENATE
WHICH ARTICLES RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR THE BILL INCINERATOR OF
MOVES THE BILL OF THE MOTIONS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. AND FOSTER
BROWN TO CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THE- QUARTERLY. THE FIVE. ZERO
BOOK. OPPOSE BY OPPOSE.
NOVARTIS JUST TO CLARIFY IS THE
TURNOVER I KNOW VOTE CENTER BY
THE TRAVEL BUG NO SENATOR
DORADO HI SENATOR REID SO HI
CENTER LAYER HI CENTER LAYERED
BY CENTER NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
STERN NEWMAN I FOR ONE DO SO
THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS.
WELCOME CENTER STERN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE- IN
ACCOMMODATIONS TODAY- TO THE
GENERAL LITTLE BIT OUT OF ORDER
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL SB
TWO EIGHTY FOUR. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON A- FIRST
HEARING HERE- HONORED TO BE
BRINGING THIS BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY IT'S A IT'S A HEAVY
SUBJECT- WHEN I WORKED ON FOR A
FEW YEARS HERE- AROUND
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS INJURIES
AND YOU KNOW WE INITIALLY AFTER
GOING THROUGH. SOME REALLY
TRAUMATIC FIRES AND- I MASS
SHOOTING IN MY DISTRICT A FEW
YEARS BACK STARTED LOOKING AT
THE IMPACT THAT THESE KINDS OF
INCIDENTS WERE HAVING ON THE-
FIRST RESPONDERS OF ALL KINDS-
AND LOOKING AT HOW WORKERS
COMPENSATION ACCOUNTS FOR THE
KINDS OF INJURIES. THAT THOSE
WORKERS HAVE AS A MATTER OF
COURSE IN THEIR BUSINESS- IN
THEIR WORK THAT THEIR WORK HAS
INHERENTLY DRAMATIC QUALITIES
TO IT THEY REALLY MAKE PUTTING
THE BURDEN ON THE WORKER TO
PROVE THAT THEY'VE GONE THROUGH
SOME POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS
INJURY- THAT THAT BURDEN WHEN
IT IS ON THE BACK OF THE WILL
THE WORKERS DOING THE WORK- IS
SIMPLY- INCONTROVERTIBLE YEAR
OPPOSED TO HOW. THE WORK ITSELF
IS DONE BUT ALSO DETERS AND
STIGMATIZES THIS KIND OF TRAUMA
AND MAKES PEOPLE BURY THEIR
INJURIES AND DO WE REALLY GOING
TO CHANGE THAT SO SB FIVE FORTY
TWO A FEW YEARS BACK WAS OUR
ATTEMPT TO REALLY START TURNING
THAT BY ESTABLISHING A
PRESUMPTION- THAT WHEN A
FIREFIGHTER POLICE OFFICER
OTHER SORT OF CLASSIFICATIONS
OF FIRST RESPONDERS ARE FILING
FOR WORKERS COMP FOR
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS INJURY
THAT. THE PRESUMPTION IS THAT
THEY'RE TELLING THE TRUTH I'M
IN THE BURDENS ON THE EMPLOYER
TO PROVE THAT THEY'RE NOT AWARE
IS UNDER THE CURRENT UNDER
PREVIOUS LAW IT WAS QUITE THE
OPPOSITE SO TODAY WE'RE
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD TO
FRANKLY FILL SOME GAPS THAT WE
LEFT. IN THAT LEGISLATION-
EVERYONE FROM. NINE ONE I. TO
CERTAIN. OF PEACE OFFICERS WHO-
ALSO IN KURT EQUALLY DRAMATIC
WORK ON THE FRONT LINES-
FIREFIGHTERS- FOLKS WHO WORK IN
OUR STATE HOSPITAL SYSTEM- AND
FORMER SOCIALS- DEPARTMENT GOT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. PARK
RANGERS- AND SO HOPEFULLY THIS
LEGISLATION REMEDIES HE THE BIG
GAP IN CURRENT LAW WE'RE WE'RE
NOT APPLYING ONLY A STANDARD
THAT IS IN PLACE BECAUSE OF THE
INHERENT. NATURE THESE PERFECT.
SO YOU KNOW I MEAN IT'S GONNA
DO A WORSE JOB THAN OUR LEAD
WITNESSES HERE AND- THEIR
STORY- SO I HOPE PEOPLE LISTEN
IN AN I KNOW YOU'RE BUSY BUT
LET ME ARREARS AND UNDERSTAND
THAT WHEN SOMEONE'S ON THE
OTHER END OF THAT NINE ONE ONE
PHONE CALL. OR YOU ENGAGE WITH
THAT YOU KNOW THAT FIREFIGHTER
OR SOMEONE YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE A LOT OF ONE OF THE
STATE HOSPITAL IN A- NECK. ED
TRAUMATIC EVENT- THAT THOSE ARE
REAL PEOPLE HAVE TO GO HOME AT
NIGHT AND THE SUICIDE RATES-
INCIDENCES OF MENTAL HEALTH.
AND ADDICTION I'M THESE ARE
TOUGH THINGS TO TALK ABOUT BUT
WE FRANKLY HAVE TO- IF WE'RE
GOING TO STAND UP TO THE PEOPLE
STAND UP FOR US. SO I'M HAPPY
TO GET INTO I REALLY APPRECIATE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND I AM
HAPPY TO GIVE SOME FEEDBACK
THERE- THERE WERE SOME
ANALOGIES TO. WHAT PEOPLE FACE
SAY IN TERMS OF PROVING A
NEGATIVE IN TERMS OF- BE CITY-
I THINK THIS IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT CASE IN TERMS OF
PROVING THE NEGATIVE AROUND
THIS TRAUMA BUT- LET ME GET
INTO IT INTO A MORE DETAILED
MEMBERS WOULD SUGGEST AND- WITH
THAT I'LL JUST I'LL PASS IT
OVER TO OUR VERY ABLE WITNESSES
HERE I KNOW WE'VE GOT- TURNING
FROM CSL EA. AS WELL AS- I ONE
OF THE LEAD OPERATORS IN THE
STATE ON A NINE ONE ONE- AND I
THINK WE'RE WE'RE LUCKY ENOUGH
TO ACTUALLY HAVE- ONE OF OUR
UNITED PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AS WELL ALONG WITH
THAT SO I'LL TURN IT OVER TO I
THINK IT'S RYAN- NAVARRETE-
TINA BRAZIL AND- NIKKI.
IMPASTATO WE THINK IS- RENOVAR
OF IS- FOR- I. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IF YOU'RE ON LAW YOU
MAY PLEASE- YOURSELF IN PERCY.
HI AM THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS RYAN THE BAR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION. WE ARE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR WHICH IS LARGELY A
CLEANUP BILL TO SB FIVE FORTY
TWO FROM TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THAT PROVIDES PEACE OFFICERS
AND FIREFIGHTERS WITH THE PTSD
PRESUMPTION. UNDER THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM. OUR
BARGAINING UNIT REPRESENTING
VARIOUS STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
DISPATCHER CLASSIFICATIONS THAT
PROVIDE MUTUAL AID ANSWERED
STATE DEPARTMENTS THAT RESPOND
TO AND SEE THE SAME HORRIFIC
EVENTS THAT LEAVES CITY AND
COUNTY POLICE OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS. WITH PTSD. SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR ADDS VARIOUS PEACE
OFFICER AND FIREFIGHTER
CLASSIFICATIONS INTO THAT
PRESUMPTION. FOR THESE REASONS
WE ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. AND
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO TINA
BRAZIL. I AM HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU- THE PLEASE STAND BY HIS OR
QUESTIONS MISTER BARIS- TINA
BRAZIL ARE YOU ONLINE IF SO
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND
YOU MAY PROCEED. HI MY NAME IS
TINA BRAZIL. ON PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHERS
APPROPRIATION AND SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION. I AM A FULL TIME
DISPATCHER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL AND HAVE BEEN
FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS NOW.
IMAGINE IF YOU CAN YOUR WORST
NIGHTMARE OCCURRING RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU AND THEN TRYING TO
DEAL AND COPE WITH IT. IMAGINE
THE DISPATCHER RECEIVING THESE
TYPES OF CALLS ALMOST EVERY DAY
FOR THEIR ENTIRE CAREER. I
DISPATCHER THAT TAKES A CALL
FROM A SUICIDAL WOMAN THAT GOES
INTO THE DELTA MENDOTA CANAL IN
AS YOUR CAR WAS THINKING SHE
CHANGE YOUR MIND. THE
DISPATCHER TRIED WITH VERY
LITTLE TIME TO GET YOUR
LOCATION AND COULD NOT. AS YOU
HEARD THE WOMAN SCREAMING AND
CRYING AS THE VEHICLE SANK IN
THE WATER. AS EMERGENCY
DISPATCHERS WE EXPERIENCE THESE
TERRIBLE EVENTS IN REAL TIME.
FAMILIES TRYING TO ESCAPE WITH
JUST THEIR LIVES FROM RAVAGING
FLAMES OF THE WILDFIRES. AFTER
WHAT THEY SHOULD DO IN THEIR
LIFE OR DEATH WHITE BRIDESMAIDS
TRAPPED IN A BURNING LEVINE
ALABAMA CAMBRIDGE THERE CHOKING
AND BLINDED BY THICK SMOKE AS
THE QUESTION BOND BY THE
FOLLOWING. BRIEL CALLED REAL
STRESS THE PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHER YOUR CALL AFTER
CALL. EMOTIONAL PLEA FOR LIFE
SAVING HELP. YOUR ACTIONS TAKE
THE LIFE OF THE PERSON YOU ARE
TALKING TO YOU MUST REMAIN CALM
WILL BE QUICK THANK YOU. THERE
ARE FEW THINGS MORE STRESSFUL
ON ONE CALL AFTER ANOTHER. CAN
BE JUST LIKE THAT. VERY LITTLE
CAREER. THAT COULD BE MOST
DEFINITELY RESULT OF DRAMATIC
WITH. THAT SOMETHING FOR
DEFECTIVE THAT HELP THEM WITH
THEIR HAVE BEEN BELOW THEIR
FAVORITE AND MENTAL WELL WILL
CARE FOR THEM OKAY GOOD FOR
MANY IN NEED OF A MURDER
ASSISTANCE. FOR THIS REMEMBER
ARE JOHN. I LEFT MAJORITY. A
BILL THAT WOULD. FOR REALIZE
WHO CALLED COVERAGE WITH YES
MA'AM NOT THAT I URGE ALBUM. IS
BRAZIL- WE WILL MOVE ON NOW TO
CAMPUS IS YOU'RE ONLINE. UP
FOR- SO FOR THE- YOU MAY PURSUE.
YES I'M HERE THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME NIKKI THE
START AND I'M NOT BY DISPATCH
FOR THE COSTA COUNTY FOR COULD
THIS AND A MEMBER OF COSTA
COUNTY COULD FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL
THIRTY. I HAVE BEEN AND I
WANTED FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS AND
FIRE DISPATCH SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN THANK YOU FOR HEARING
MY STORY. IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I TOOK A NINE ONE ONE
CALL FROM AN ELDERLY WOMAN. ON
FIRE SHE WAS VERY DISORIENTED
AND COULD NOT GET OUT OF THE
HOUSE SHE WAS MOANING AND
TRYING TO GET MY TRYING TO
ANSWER MY QUESTIONS AS AFTER
WHAT WAS ON FIRE AND IF SHE
COULD EXIT THE RESIDENCE BUT TO
NO AVAIL. THE LINE CRACKLED AND
DISCONNECTED AND I KNEW AT THAT
POINT SHE HAD BURNED UP INSIDE
OF HER HOME. THE FIREFIGHTERS
FOUND HER BURNED BODY JUST
INSIDE. HER FRONT DOOR NEAR THE
PHONE. I TAKE IT MANY ON MY-
PEOPLE DYING BUT THIS WAS GET
FROM. I WAS CHANGED AFTER THIS
I WAS. DISCONNECTED I COULD NOT
SLEEP AT BECAME DETACHED. FIFTY
ENTER FACT MY WORK AND I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS HAPPENING
TO ME. I BECAME ANGRY MY
MARRIAGE WAS FALLING APART AND
MY KIDS DIDN'T WANT TO BE
AROUND ME. I STARTED LOOKING
FOR A PERSONAL COUNSELOR
THROUGH THE EMPLOYEE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM BUT HAD NO LUCK LOCK.
AND THEN ABOUT SIX MONTHS LATER
I GOT A REPRIMAND TO WORK.
WHICH INCLUDED GOING TO TRAUMA
TRAINING DUE TO THE FATAL FIRE
CALL. I WAS REFERRED JUDGE
COUNSELOR WHO WORKS WITH FIRST
RESPONDERS TO OUR PEER SUPPORT
PROGRAM. AND NOT DOCTOR
IMMEDIATELY. DIAGNOSED ME WITH
PTSD. MY THERAPIST OUT FOR
THREE. SHALL CAUTIONED ME THAT
ALTHOUGH MY PTS I WAS 1100%
WORK RELATED. I NEEDED TO THINK
CAREFULLY ABOUT FILING A
WORKERS COMP CLAIM BECAUSE IT
WAS GOING TO BE A LONG
STRESSFUL FLIGHT SITE. AND
SOMEONE TRYING TO HEAL FROM GPS
BY. A WORKERS COMP CLAIM WAS
GOING TO EXACERBATE THOSE
INJURIES. I ULTIMATELY DID FILE
A CLAIM. I STILL BETTER THERAPY
ONCE A WEEK I'M ON THREE
DIFFERENT MEDICATIONS AND I
STILL STRUGGLE TO SLEEP THROUGH
THE NIGHT. IT IS NINE TWO YEARS
AND I'M STILL WAITING ON
WORKERS COMP. I'VE DONE
EVERYTHING THEY'VE ASKED I'VE
EVEN DECIDED NOT TO HAVE A
LAWYER THANK YOU NOT MIGHT MOVE
MORETHINGS MORE QUICKLY. I'VE
SEEN THE CUNY DOCTOR THREE
TIMES. LAST REPORT SAYS I AM
1100% DISABLED DUE TO WORK BUT
NOW THEY'RE PICKING APART MY
INJURY ANSWERS REPORT. I HAVE
FOLLOWED ALL OF THEIR
INSTRUCTIONS WITHOUT DELAY AND
STILL LIGHT WEIGHT. SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR RECOGNIZES THAT
DISPATCHERS ARE TRULY FIRST
RESPONDERS AND THAT EITHER WE
OUR BODIES OR MINDS FORGET OUR
PATIENTS AND OUR CALLERS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR LISTENING TO MY
STORY AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT BELL. OKAY THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR OF TESTIMONY-
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ANY WITNESSES- WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
OVER HERE THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
YES SIR PLEASE PROCEED AND
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. MICROPHONE
ON IT IS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY NUMBER
ASSOCIATION OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
NINE ONE ONE DISPATCHERS POLICE
TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
LIKE VERY QUICKLY ADD THAT WE
HAVE A SHORTAGE IN THE DISPATCH
COMMUNITY WE NEED MORE
PROFESSIONALS IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THOSE PROFESSIONALS THAT
WE HAVE WE BE ABLE TO TREAT
THEM AND GIVE THEM. THE SERVICE
AND CARE THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO RETURN THEM TO THE JOB
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER SMITH
ANYONE ELSE- IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL SO PLEASE
COME FORWARD. LET'S SEE NONE
ANYONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY WAS
SUCCESSFUL IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO EIGHTY FOUR. C. NONE WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE MODERATOR
AND ASK HIM TO PLEASE PROBABLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO EIGHTY
FOR. US SO WE CAN BEGIN PLEASE
CALL THEM INDIVIDUALLY. THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FOR S. B. TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. THE FIRST GO TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE WILL MOVE ON PLEASE
CHECK YOUR PHONE AND IF YOU
WANT TO REVIEW PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE
FIFTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS AS A DOG CHAMBERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS OR
POLICE TO. CO SPONSOR THE
MEASURE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR STERN FOR HIS ONGOING
WORK ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
MICKEY AND POSTADO FOR SHARING
HER EXPERIENCE HERE TODAY- AND
FINALLY RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE
GIRL NEXT TO. OUR NEXT LEVEL
NEXT TO LINE FIFTY. CHECKS
MISTER RUMORS RANDY CURRY WITH
THEIR LEAD ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF
OF ORAC ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER REED. OVER THE NEXT TO
LINE THIRTY ONE. HELLO THERE AB
MEMBERS MY NAME IS PATRICK FOR
A ON BEHALF OF TWO
ORGANIZATIONS ONE IS THE
CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME
WARDENS ASSOCIATION FOLLOWED BY
THE SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION URGING YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
TO LINE THIRTY FIVE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. YOUR CHAIR NUMBERS
KEEPING DATA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION KAREN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU-
IN WE WILL KNOW MOVED TO- THOSE
WHO ARE ON THE LINE WHO HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION- BELIEVE THE FIRST
SPEAKER WOULD BE FAITH BORDERS
HIS FAITH BORDERS ONLINE. IF SO
PLEASE MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
THANK YOU. FOR JUST ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY IF WE
AGREE WITH THE AUTHORS
RECOGNITION OF THE HONOR AND
DISTINCTION IN WHICH PEACE
OFFICER SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WE RECOGNIZE THE MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES THAT THESE
OFFICERS MAY ENCOUNTER- HERE
TODAY RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED SB
KENNEDY FOR. IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES MANY
INSURANCE COMPANIES WERE
UNWILLING ARE VERY RELUCTANT TO
PROVIDE INSURANCE PRODUCTS TO
PUBLIC AGENCIES THE PUBLIC
ENTITY RISK POOLING JPA FOR
ESTABLISHING AS A RESULT MANY
PUBLIC ENTITIES USE THAT MODEL
TO EFFECTIVELY SELL FUND FOR
WORKERS COMPENSATION COVERAGE.
AND NONPROFIT JPA THE BENEFITS
PROPOSED BY SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR
OR TAX PAYER FUNDED AND MERIT
THOUGHTFUL RUBIO. ALL
PRESUMPTIONS EVEN EVEN
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
ESTABLISHING NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
BAR FOR EMPLOYERS TO PROVE AND
NEGATIVE THAT. ILLNESS IS NOT
WORK RELATED. SB TWO EIGHTY.
AND PTSD PRISON CREATED BY SB
FIVE FORTY KILL TWO ELECTIVE
CLASSIFICATIONS WHICH INCLUDES
PEACE OFFICERS THAT OUR
INVESTIGATORS WITH THE DENTAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WORK FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES AND ANY PEACE OFFICERS
EMPLOYED BY K. TWELVE PUBLIC
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND MANY MORE
WERE UNAWARE OF ANY OBJECTIVE
ANALYSIS THAT THESE
CLASSIFICATIONS MERIT THE
ELIMINATION OF STATUTORY CLAIMS
REVIEW PROCEDURES. BUT A
COMPANY WORKERS COMPENSATION
PTSD PRESUMPTION OR THAT
THEY'RE EVEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY PTSD AND FACT IN
INTERNAL REVIEW OF CLAIMS DATA
TELLS US THAT PTSD CLAIMS ARE
INFREQUENT AND EVERY CLAIM THAT
WAS RELATED TO WORK WITH
ACCEPTED. AND I'LL THE SITE
CLAIMS THAT WERE APPROPRIATE
AND MOST CLAIMS DIRECTLY
FOLLOWED A DISCIPLINARY ACTION
FOR AN OFFICER OVER FILED RIGHT
BEFORE RETIREMENT WHICH IT
STANDS ONLY INCREASES PENSION
BENEFITS FOR AN OFFICER
CONFRONTING STIGMA MASS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE PTSD AS AN
IMPORTANT POLICY OBJECTIVES
WHICH WE SHARE WITH THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS HOWEVER MANDATING
AND CHECK TO TAXPAYER FUNDED
BENEFITS. GOING ON JOB TITLE IS
NOT THE SOLUTION AND IGNORES
NECESSARY POLICY AND FISCAL
CONSIDERATIONS WE WELCOME THE
ADDITIONAL REVIEW BY CATHOLIC
THAT WILL BE DISCUSSED BY THE
FOLLOWING SPEAKER AND WE'D BE
HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THEN COMMITTEE ON A
BROADER CONVERSATION ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH AND PRODUCTION
ELIGIBILITY THAT EXAMINES THE
IMPACT THAT SUCH CHANGES WOULD
HAVE ON INJURED WORKERS. AND ON
LOCAL BUDGETS PRIOR TO FOR THE
COVERAGE EXPANSION HOWEVER AT
THE TIME WHERE RESPECTFULLY.
OPPOSED SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER DISABILITY WE
HAVE COULD. SMELSER POINT TO
TESTIFY UP. IF SO PLEASE ENTER
YOURSELF YOU SEE. YEAH THANK
YOU MISTER- MEMBERS- MY IS
CHASE SCHMELZER HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND PRISM- THE
PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT. SB
TWO EIGHTY FOUR OR EXPAND AN
EXISTING PRESUMPTION THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THREE SB FIVE FORTY TWO ALSO BY
SENATOR STERN MUCH OF THE
CONVERSATION AROUND SB FIVE
FORTY TWO WAS FOCUSED ON THE
STIGMA CONNECTED WITH SEEKING
TREATMENT FOR TRAUMA IS
ASSOCIATED WITH PUBLIC SAFETY
EMPLOYMENT. HOWEVER THERE IS
REALLY NO EVIDENCE- AT THE TIME
I PROVIDED THAT WOULD
SUBSTANTIATE REALLY IN ANY WAY
THAT AN ACTUAL PROBLEM EXISTS
WITH THE FUNCTIONALITY OF THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM. IS MADE OR
HOW IT- PROCESSES PTSD CLAIMS-
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY. OFFICERS
WITH OR WITHOUT A PRESUMPTION.
THE SIMPSONS IN THE WORK COMP
AND SYSTEM- THEY DON'T REDUCE
STIGMAS OR MAKE THE SYSTEM MORE
FAIR EQUITABLE FOR EMPLOYEES
PRESUMPTIONS SHIFT THE BURDEN
OF PROOF SO THAT EMPLOYERS
CANNOT EFFECTIVELY. MOVING NON
OCCUPATIONAL CLAIMS OUT OF THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM
INTO OTHER BENEFITS SYSTEMS. IN
THIS CASE- AN EMPLOYER MUCH
PROVED THAT PTSD DID NOT ARISE
FROM EMPLOYMENT IN OTHER WORDS
AS THE ANALYSIS INDICATES. THE
LAW WOULD REQUIRE US TO PROVE
IN SCIENTIFIC NEGATIVE I WHICH
ISN'T ENTIRELY POSSIBLE- AS I
MENTIONED PAGE TO THE ANALYSIS
AS A REALLY GOOD JOB OF KIND OF
WALKING THROUGH THIS DYNAMIC AS
IT RELATES TO OUR HEART
PRESUMPTION. BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT- THE TYPE OF
POLICY THAT WE'RE CONSIDERING
HERE MAKES IT VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR EMPLOYERS. I TO
REFUTE INJURIES AND ILLNESSES
THAT ARE FALSELY OR ARONIE
ISLEY CLAIMED AS WORK RELATED-
FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES THIS MEANS
THAT PUBLIC RESOURCES ARE
UNNECESSARILY DIVERTED AWAY
FROM PUBLIC BENEFIT- IT'S BEEN
OBSERVED IN THE PAST THE
PRESUMPTION SHOULD BE. USED
INFREQUENTLY AND ONLY WENT BACK
BY MEANINGFUL DATA OF THE PRIOR
SPEAKER I NOTED THE COMMISSION
ON HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
WORKERS COMPENSATION IS
CURRENTLY CONDUCTING A STUDY.
THAT STUDY WAS REQUESTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY- IT AT THE
TIME THAT SB FIVE FORTY TWO-
WAS PASSED IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
THAT STUDY ASKS A DOZEN VERY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS I CAN HELP
THE LEGISLATURE- CONSIDER AN
EXPANSION OF THIS POLICY AND
THAT INFORMATION JUST ISN'T
AVAILABLE YET- WORKERS
COMPENSATION IS FOR WORK
RELATED INJURIES AND ILLNESSES
ONLY. IT'S OT DOESN'T DESIGNED
OR INTENDED TO COVER- INJURIES
AND ILLNESSES THAT ARE NOT
RELATED TO EMPLOYMENT- THE
POLICY UNDER CONSIDERATION AND
SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR.
INAPPROPRIATELY BLURS THAT
LINE- AND THEREFORE WEAKENS THE
SYSTEM- THERE CONTINUES TO BE
NO OBJECTIVE JUSTIFICATION FOR
THE POLICY WE ARE THERE FOR A
OPPOSED AND. RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR NOTEBOOK TODAY. OKAY YOU
THINK FOR TO US- WE- BELIEVE
THE COULD- THOSE WHO'D TESTED.
AND I DID NOT. ON WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO COMMITTEE ROOM ASKING
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
TWO EIGHTY FOUR. IN THE ROOM IS
SOLD PLEASE STOP FOR. A SEEN
NONE OF ORDER MAKE SURE- THAT
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE TO
TESTIFY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWENTY FOUR.
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. IS IT A
FIRE. SEEN NONE- I WILL GO BACK
TO THE MODERATOR DOES THE
MODERATOR. TO QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. BUT TO S.
B. TWO EIGHTY FOUR THROUGH THE
TOLL COVERED SERVICES TO MISTER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU AND IF
THERE ARE ANY OPPOSITION- THE
VOICES TO S. B. TWO EIGHTY FOUR
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS TIME.
WE WILL FIRST GO TO LINE FIFTY
TWO GO AHEAD. SHARE MIDDLETON
AND GET ON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO NEXT TO
LINE FORTY SIX GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF
NEAL AGAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
RESPECTFULLY APPROACHED. THANK
YOU. IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
LINES THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY NOW TO PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR.
WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OR THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. OR CONCERNS IT WOULD
LIKE TO RAISE AT THIS TIME.
SEEN NONE- CENTER SURE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. SHIFTY
DISCUSSION AMONGST THE
TESTIMONY TODAY- AND MOSTLY I
WANT TO THANK NIKKI FOR HER
BRAVE TESTIMONY- IF YOU WERE
WILLING TO SHARE YOUR STORY AND
COME A FORCE IN THE LEGISLATURE
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE
OUT THERE WITH THAT SAME STORY
WHO ARE NOT TELLING IT HERE
TODAY WE'RE NOT GOING THROUGH
THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
PROCESS TO BEGIN WITH. BECAUSE
BETTER LIVING WITH STIGMA AND
FEAR WE THINK THAT THIS
ACTUALLY IS AN INCREDIBLY
EFFECTIVE TOOL TO BREAKING THAT
CYCLE AND OPEN. ADDING PEOPLE
PASSED THE NOTION THAT THIS IS
SOME DISORDER TO BE- ASHAMED OF
INSTEAD IT'S AN INJURY THAT
GOES ALONG WITH THE JOB. M. AND
THESE ARE OUR JOBS SO THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU TO ALL
THE WITNESSES THEY CONSIDER
STERN PER. BRING BILL FORWARD.
AND WE'RE LOOKING FOR MOTION ON
THE BILL. OF OKAY IT IS SO- BY
SENATOR TO RUSSELL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PHILOSOPHER BOMB
THE ROLE AT THIS TIME. FOR THE
RECORD CLOSING BY THEREFORE
FIVE SENATOR OCHO BOAT. BOATING
THE ORIGINAL BOOK NOT VOTING
CENTER DORADO. SENATOR RESO PI
CENTER LAYERED BY DINNER
LAYERED HI CENTER NEWMAN.
CENTER NEWMAN HI FOR ROADS.
LOSERS THANK YOU- AGAIN ONE
THINK OF OLD FOR THE WITNESSES
IN THE PARTICIPATION OF THAT WE
HAD TODAY- THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE- IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO S. FORTY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT. TO US AND WE WANT TO
COULD YOU TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR ALL YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANKS EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION- PARTICULARLY-
THOSE WHO WERE WAITING IN LINE
TO TESTIFY WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA IN THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON THE REPUBLICAN RETIREMENT IS
NO INSURANCE. YEAH YOU KNOW I
WITH A DIGITAL AND HAS STATED
THAT WILL.